[Music]
hey everybody welcome
hi are we live we are live
to h3 after dark skeleton crew that's
we're a little bit late today
obviously we had some modifications for
ela in mind
um
why have we modified the set for you
hilo
my back pain is at
full
one thousand percent
um
it's okay but you should tuck in
alfredo's
sorry
[Music]
so
yeah this is um i knew this was coming
it happened last pregnancy too
but at the
pretty much about like the last two
months i have horrible back pain it's
just unbearable because
the stomach gets so big and then it's
like
your body is just all wonky
and i have back pain
uh regardless
yeah she was saying i don't think i can
make it
today because of the back pain
we said well well let's just set you up
a bed
how's your back is that okay for your
back yeah trevor likes it by the way
alfredo's also laying on ela a little
lower but you can't uh
you can't see him
all right well here we are
we made it thanksgiving stopping us from
going live that's right we barely made
it that's right almost doxxed myself
did drop a curse word in the first
second i said [ __ ] great but that one i
think that that word is up there they
said it's okay now yes i'll see okay
this is literally a true test
i mean it's not the best way to open
your video [ __ ]
maybe maybe it got cut out
no
jesus at least i didn't say you know the
f word that might have been really
screwed
didn't we that happened to us once
before and we just canceled the show and
restarted it we did that one time yeah
we did that before is that worth it
probably not now no yeah it's just that
it's just
it's just [ __ ]
uh today's episode is sponsored by honey
thank you to them we love them
how's everyone feeling
good
how's everyone feeling who are we
missing today
i know one person we're missing
oh
gabe
gabe is with us gabe how was your
thanksgiving
still connecting his audio there there
we go
happy thanksgiving happy thanksgiving
gabe how was your thanksgiving
good
yeah having my leftovers enjoying my
leftover
mac and cheese let's get a close-up of
the plate
some turkey some stuffing what's that
thing
oh the cranberries crayon cranberry
cranberry jello that's what i call it
hell yeah
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] yeah but they [ __ ] you
have any chance to do any black friday
shopping um today
yeah you you could go to actually the
best place to do black friday shopping's
at teddyfresh.com
up to 50 off
all right there you go yeah what are you
thinking of are you thinking of doing
any shopping
maybe maybe later you know it's probably
busy at the mall right now everybody oh
yeah oh yeah it's good deals and stuff
are you are you can i ask you are your
lips
do you have chapstick on or is that just
turkey i think that's turkey turkey
that's a juicy turkey
oh yeah oh yeah nice and glossy
did you make anything
[Laughter]
nothing much it's just the gravy oh you
made the gravy that's that's
a contribution you know the gravy is
very uh
it interacts with so many ingredients i
think it's it's very important put any
uh peppermint oil in it
i don't know okay yeah yeah that's a
good call all right baby
baby all right
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
baby
[ __ ] yeah you're gonna have a great
weekend i'm i'm sure
with the family and a little [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] baby yeah yeah
i got things going on this weekend
not just thanksgiving and shopping maybe
hey can i can i ask what are you guys
doing with the febreze bottle in the
kitchen
we gotta spray the kitchen because when
you cook food in the kitchen it's it
gives that order that meat order turkey
order
yes so you guys
okay so you guys are just trying to get
the lingering smell of meat out of the
kitchen
oh yeah oh yeah baby interesting okay
fascinating stuff
oh someone's at the door you want to
answer it
oh somebody
someone else got it okay
all right gabe well hey you take care it
seems like you're busy enjoying
thanksgiving with them
leftovers hell yeah oh someone said the
door
you got it
someone got it okay okay all right all
right well [ __ ] baby
no work no school
you know
that's the way to do it that is the way
to do it it's the only way to do it
all right gabe you have a good one okay
we'll see you next week have a good one
all right
all right love you baby [ __ ] baby
love that man absolutely seems like he
had a good thanksgiving that's good
that's very awesome
yeah i was going to ask what is shredder
i'm sure that is just his bum on the on
the pillow and his two
legs down that's an interesting posture
there yeah are you comfortable
okay
um
how was your guys's thanksgiving it was
good
low-key
with the close family and everything
it was nice
yeah yep oh you were gonna say who's
missing here oh yeah what abe is missing
sort of he's actually
right here oh oh why you dude how cold
is it there god damn is it really cold
yeah
uh i think the heat's out in the house
and my brother's at work it's the
biggest jacket i've ever seen
it's it's legit it works somewhere here
yeah i know like i was wondering if i
can even pull off this shirt jacket
the thing is like 75 here in los angeles
i forgot how much i hate the cold it is
the worst
well
thank me when you get home
you got it
becky i mean what the [ __ ] you shouldn't
have to sit in your own home in a
goddamn like eskimo oh that's israel
antarctic yeah i guess so
we used to do that in israel and it's
like you don't think of israel as a cold
place but the ac there sucks and
whatever the temperature is outside it's
inside your house it sucks it's
expensive insulation's horrible yeah
insulation like doesn't exist nobody has
central ac
i guess if you have like a modern new
house then you're probably fine
yeah like nobody has that
well wait how does the ac not work in
detroit isn't that like a death sentence
there i mean it was working earlier that
i don't know i the heat's not working
right now i don't know if my brother
turned it off when he went to work or
something he's like [ __ ] this kid
my brother is a cheap ass so possibly i
don't know oh my god that's pretty
brutal to turn it turn that [ __ ] off on
you
yeah this house was built in 1920 so
it's like super old too oh my goodness
okay is there any way to get a reading
on the temperature inside
there's a nest app but i don't know it's
like it's not like usually when you turn
the heat up you could hear it but i'm
not hearing anything i'm seeing the
numbers move but i'm not hearing the
heat kick in so it says it's 29 degrees
in detroit right now oh
wow let's go
oh my god
back in paradise wait i gotta know how
what's the temperature in that house
i don't know how i can i mean just look
at his jacket you know
is there is lena there with you is lean
in that house too
lina yeah she's upstairs i want to see
what she's wearing all right all right
grab her yeah bring her back we'll check
back in on you guys
holy god dude
29 degrees
i guess we're spoiled here in los
angeles i can't even imagine you so i
was like wait is it it's like still
summer kind of here
29 middle of the day holy smokes
well anyway we'll check back on on them
it sounds like everybody had a good
thanksgiving
um ryan cavanaugh had a really good
thanksgiving i'll get into that later
though
i had a great thanksgiving
ryan cavanaugh was sitting by himself
drinking and editing my wikipedia page
and posting
i'm sorry it's just so funny you guys
i'll keep it short
ryan cavanaugh was posting to about his
variety articles to instagram on
thanksgiving
yeah it's sad
here i'll show it but he'd erased one of
them
look at this [ __ ] bro
wait what is he doing here
what is going on on his webs on his
instagram
what a nightmare
um her post
equity [ __ ] wait whoa whoa he erased it
he erased it again you guys
he posted it twice
anyways and he erased it twice
so what's going on hang on we got to go
to the subreddit to find the archive on
this one
um
i mean there's a there's a whole thing
in the dock about it there is okay cool
i'm just this is super funny you guys
and sad so i'm just gonna hit it real
fast just because it interests me
okay so
by the way ryan apparently in the
editor's notes on wikipedia before he
got banned him and his seven soccer
puppets said that he's the one that got
us suspended from youtube he said i have
all press much more recent and copies of
legal actions against h3 for attempting
to seminate these very same falsehoods
if you would like to review them
by the way he's talking to like a wiki
mod or like a wikipedia editor if you
would like to review my files on files
yeah
of falsehoods if you like to review them
as well as copies of the legal
complaints sent to youtube which
ultimately resulted in them being banned
with two strikes for a week and now
hopefully permanently twitch is also
reviewing the same info for a band
yo now that is such a twist in the story
okay well i think it proves one thing
that he did send legal complaints to to
youtube and for some reason twitch like
he's trying to get me d platform for
saying he he's a douche
but who's who actually got us banned
because we also know that kimstar did
too well it was con it was keemstar it
was definitely yeah
he's trying to take credit for it
it also might be evidence that him and
keemstar are more closely um
yeah working together than we previously
thought they definitely got a group chat
going on or something h3 or ethan klein
uh
victim chat support group
all jews
well ryan cavanaugh is a jew oh that's
true
i'm busted
dan is filling in for zach on the sound
bites everybody today
we're coming in with the all jews we
love [ __ ] garbage okay all right
right here behind me
yeah so
so
the thing is we got the band for
something we said about keemstar
but i'm in a sea of slander and lies
yeah imagine how harvey i mean uh ryan
cavanaugh feels
so he sent legal complaints to youtube
can you believe this [ __ ] i mean i'm
[ __ ] rolling in it and then
uh we i think we showed this but yeah he
has like 20 this is so embarrassing for
him he has like seven sock puppet
accounts all linked to his ip
that all got [ __ ] banned
i think we talked about this uh last on
our last episode a bit right
look at all this bitching please
it's just
paid to disseminate false
bro i just
this is him crying to editors on
wikipedia
but the best part comes
um
he apparently has been editing
my wikipedia page
but it's just a link to this fight video
dan
by the way this is uh this was posted on
october 7th this is the figurehead of a
new age media company
yeah posted a video and glorious
144 p
no other option
uh straight to youtube guys triller
verse 3 is here
ryan kavanagh what to expect from
triller
triller
[Music]
maybe he just does this because he knows
how disgusting he is to look at the best
in verses um
i mean
that's a combination of everybody knows
i know it's mean
but he's also a [ __ ] lunatic the
icons of r b
and then it was like if you're a disc
not even like
if you're like as disgusting inside and
out as ryan kavanagh is you would want
to broadcast at 144p
boxers um together in one night it's a
combat night shut up
yeah so what i was getting to is the
where is the i put it in the discord oh
you did okay yeah it wasn't in the dark
thank you yeah so
he posted first of all
um
he posted this
hold on this is
there's a big post with all the photos
and stuff
all right let me find it
it's it's in the dark
um
where it says re-upload of the post
yeah so here's what i wanted to show you
guys so on thanksgiving day
he posted this deleted it
you got to see this [ __ ]
this man
is living
life
um he said
people been asking about what variety
wrote about me
posting it here was a true honor
yeah ela
no i'm just uh confused why did he post
this
yeah uh
okay do you guys notice something odd
here
variety showman of the year
and it's literally like on the phone he
scribbled out the year like really
shittily
right
and can you make it out
well it was like you know
hello long ago 2011 yeah 2011. he's like
people have been asking about what
variety wrote about
well it's been such an honor
let me just go back in time real quick
by the way ryan do you know what they've
written about you since then
brian cavanaugh
ponzi
well i misspelled it but they'll get the
idea oh what the [ __ ] this is in variety
too ryan kavanaugh accused my ex part of
writing a ponzi scheme and this is from
2019 way more
uh
way more modern
you forgot to include that
and then he posted this weird photo too
like here there's so many of them it's
just so interesting
ryan
cavanaugh look at this guys look at the
look at the year
do you see this
it's beautiful
what the [ __ ]
modern art
bro what the [ __ ]
he's basically saying
um
the year is just a number you know right
a little r kelly yeah by the way here's
another one scribbled out
in black
so he's matching the background colors
interesting
he's there's some strategic photo of him
yeah by the way this is a generous photo
i mean
i just saw you in 144p let's come in
ryan cavanaugh showman of the year
was this before after he got a dui hit
and run after
that was after
yeah that happened in the 2000s so he
was like hey i'm i can do this and i'm
good
yeah
people like him don't suffer
consequences from anything that they do
so all right
so there you go ryan still on top of the
world
so yes what happened he posted it then
immediately deleted so according to this
post
he deleted it within 19 seconds but then
he reposted it i guess without the
shittily edited it out
uh years because that was super mega
cringe
no that was in there in the second one
too i think
yeah this one's still up
this one's still up on it or is this a
screenshot
no it's it's still um yeah it's still oh
i didn't see it so this is he so he
reposted this is a link to his instagram
page now
okay
and by the way he was arguing with
people in the comments too uh look at
this uh conversation wait is this how
you're spending your thanksgiving oof
and then ryan actually responded to a
random instagram troll if you're alone
trolling for thanksgiving feel free to
join my family and i even trolls need a
place to be
not spending that much attention to your
family bro
he said
someone said it's because his wife went
out for pizza without me
wait did he erase the other comments
because he said
oh cam's coming through with it i think
oh here you go this is actually
uh also posted
this is [ __ ] just sad thank you a
happy thanksgiving from the weinstein oh
we mean kavanaugh family
and it appears to be a sad man sitting
at a big table by himself with my
wikipedia page open
or his wikipedia page open
we love that don't we folks
so was it still edited out because i
didn't notice maybe he did it slicker
like where's it edited out
here check the first one
where is it edited oh wait this isn't
the first one where is it edited out
edited
top right
top right top
right oh what
what a weirdo
may 10
20. he just he didn't successfully edit
it out edit it why am i saying edited
do you think you know so
on his phone over the y too yeah variety
yes
it's also on every page unedited
not the first page like at the very top
yeah that's when i'm so confused why is
he trying to hide the date just in the
first just in the first day does he want
people to think that he just got this
award
i think he's just super sloppy he's used
to having people do everything for him
no but seriously is he wanting people to
think he just got this award or
something is that why he's removing the
date
maybe like potentially confuse you like
what's his goal in in removing the day
yeah
super interesting
yeah so this is up now
um and he got owned did you guys have
that whole conversation because it seems
to be erased
thank you baby you read my mind
yeah so
uh
this guy responded to his invitation to
join him for thanksgiving said i live
outside the united states so if you want
to pay for my flights i'll happily come
share in your annual festivities i
didn't realize your family was asking
about variety magazine articles maybe
show them the one where ryan cavanaugh
was accused by ex-partner of running a
ponzi scheme
kind of set himself up in the most
ultimate and obvious way
oh
[ __ ]
so that that's just my little kavanaugh
update
it's [ __ ] crazy huh
yep
also emily baker shout outs to emily
baker she covered our recent um
as you know rank have not suing us two
two lawsuits one for defamation
one for copyright infringement the
defamation one is going through the
courts currently we had a uh oral
hearing on it
and emotion
and
triller says
as the defendants write it and i will
use their words this is what they said
in court this this is from the court
document
get ready get ready from the transcript
this is what trailer's argument said in
court
i will use their words
it is
farcical for triller to argue that any
rational person would believe that
ethan's review made a statement of
provable fact when he said he would
prefer a colonoscopy from a chain-link
fence
a dirty sanchez on a scorching day in
delhi valley
or to listen to david dobrik's
luciferian
demon laughter play on loop till as his
ears bleed for using the triller app
such a statement cannot be construed as
asserting a statement of fact yeah if
you guys want to know how [ __ ] dumb
their lawyers are in their argument
because the lawsuit itself is just
totally without merit
explicitly just to harass us and
if you want to know how dumb their legal
arguments are he's they're arguing to
the judge that because my trailer review
that we post in the background says i'd
rather be you know castrated by chain
link i'd rather give a
colonoscopy by a chain link fence than
then use the trailer app they say i'm
lying they said that's a lie and
therefore everything i'm saying i'm like
and first my i was thinking the whole
time how dare you put those words in my
mouth how dare you assume that i'm lying
how how could you know
that i wouldn't rather have a
colonoscopy from a chain-link fence then
use your [ __ ] app how i hope i kind
of i'm i'm kind of hoping i get to post
so they can ask me hardball questions
like that how dare you put words in my
mouth sir
the fact that they would even read this
out loud
is just next level that just shows how
[ __ ] uh threadbare it's just it's a
harassment lawsuit just plain and simple
so
they're trying their best to make it
make sense but it doesn't no matter what
they say you know
also the court asked the court was like
yo truly your [ __ ] was flipped on the
lower like listen to this the judge was
like yo you're tr your [ __ ] was flipped
rating and the court says okay let me
ask you this i hear you okay i hear you
can it be assumed that the app users
there's a certain behavior that app
users may have
none of it was presented here but do app
users come and go i mean
don't
i don't know what is presented
periodically do app users get
dissatisfied if a camera is inverted
the court asked
the court asked triller's lawyer
yeah but is it flipped
yeah the court asked trailers user
could app users be upset because your
[ __ ] is flipped yeah because again their
judges was like ethan has caused in
incalculable damage to us with these
negative reviews and the judge is like
well how do we know that the negative
reviews aren't because your app is
actually [ __ ] flipped yo trailer my
things flip straight from noah beck the
ambassador you know what i mean do you
think noah beck knows that he kind of
started uh oh yeah
uh it's so awkward yeah he definitely
does
that's what oh it's so awkward said noah
back
[ __ ]
ambassador source well he never he has a
vested interest in that app absolutely
succeeding you know isn't he sponsored
by them too i think he even has a bit of
equity in the company
so he's trustworthy yeah exactly he's a
reliable narrator totally
sad
but was it flipped yes
oh
my god yeah
but
are users dissatisfied if a camera is
inverted or whatever the issue that was
raised here uh and go somewhere else and
then come back like do app users get mad
because it's flipped the report is not
known
anyway go watch her um
yeah go watch her coverage it's really
good and you can see just how much uh
they're getting dominated in court
i think we're really close to taking a
dub on the
hell yes on the uh
anti-slap
and then we can pursue legal fees so all
of a sudden ryan cav cav's going to be
on the back foot there a little bit
which would be fine oh yeah hell yeah
dream is excited about that yeah a
little bit about noah back
he works on the executive team and is an
advisor
with equity shares in trailer
to advise him not to put his criticism
of the app on [ __ ] public
it's so awkward
yo trailer your kid is flipped
wow shareholder
uh quote noah beck
shareholder and advisor to triller yo
triller my thing's flipped
[ __ ] you right gavin are you [ __ ] ass
so anyway that's that
uh sorry to uh sorry to go there just
i can't help it it's on my mind
apparently he said in the footnotes of a
wikipedia page while arguing with an
editor that he's about to file a third
lawsuit against us yeah for his wicked
sorry but doesn't it just work that if
somebody adds correct information it
will make it to the wikipedia page right
that stuff should be on his wikipedia
page and it would be if he wasn't paying
people to [ __ ] keep it clean like
dude
it's crazy bro just sue me again man who
gives a [ __ ] just [ __ ] i'm just
defending myself bro that's all i've
ever done i enough sued i've never sued
anyone in my life
people sue me and i'm just defending
myself so ryan if you want a third
lawsuit over the wikipedia page he's
also he also
he also promised to include the editors
of what of the wikipedia page in the
lawsuit
okay
yeah and by the way i don't think
wikipedia wants a precedent of their
editors being sued that would pretty
much discourage anyone from using it so
wikipedia
might want to come down hard on uh
oh
[ __ ] rank kavanagh
anyway that's it
all right
thank you
thank you
what's going on
oh so
today's black friday is today black
friday
yes so why did we get screwed over that
one time so hard i'm so confused about
how we messed up
when we were in santa cruz living
together yeah we wanted to buy a laptop
on black friday
we went to we went in the middle of the
morning
and we got the day wrong and i don't
know what how we [ __ ] up because we
went
to best buy
5 a.m
and it was closed nobody was there and
we were like
where are we what happened
so if you were to go
um how go early would it have been
yesterday so people were in line today
at 5 00 a.m
see that's what i thought we did did we
go on thanksgiving day
that would be a thursday night
that would have been a problem yeah
we must have gone on thursday
thanksgiving day
yeah because that that was my first
black friday and we didn't have a good
sense of stuff because we were just a
bunch of [ __ ] a couple of [ __ ]
living in santa cruz we didn't have like
thanksgiving dinner or anything yeah
yeah it was a burrito yeah we were like
we went home and shame had a burrito the
saltiest burrito ever made never forget
and we just had we kept chugging water
all day because our bodies were like
decap or decaying from the inside
so much water
well um we had a we had some successful
black friday
uh stories to share
um
well wait until you see the video okay
well um
basically we have a report from young
ian is that right someone said in the
chat black friday bro yeah
of black friday it's in the [ __ ] name
bro
you're right and i didn't i didn't think
about that but you're absolutely right
it's in the name
well don't be thinking about that i went
on thursday i went on thursday
to a black friday sale yeah
they used to be and i didn't realize
that until right now
and i totally went with you yeah you
well you to be fair you're like fresh
off the boat yeah you're just following
my lead
oh god
all right well what do we got roll it
okay you want to set it up ian you want
to say anything i mean we have a clip
from a b and we have a clip from ian
right no just just ian oh a b failed
my clip went south real quick you want
to talk about it
i i have some crazy cousins
okay i hope this doesn't make you sound
like oh i want to see what lina's
wearing i forgot
oh here we go
one sec
oh my god
so is it so it's 29 degrees
detroit right now
and the heating appears to have stopped
working is that right lena
this is correct it's freezing here oh my
god what can we do for you guys
flying back out to l.a
yeah
you've done enough thank you for saving
us from this living house are you guys
just miserable right now
yeah i feel bad for her i'm okay but she
was like really shivering a little bit
earlier but well what the hell guys you
gotta get to a warm place what the [ __ ]
if we go to her parents house they're
just going to make us do manual labor so
i don't know
that'll warm you up
no i'm kidding
they did yesterday but yeah that's true
um
wait why don't you call your brother and
to ask if the heat is on he's at work
he's a waiter he doesn't have his phone
on him oh
yeah
what the [ __ ]
but after this we'll probably go to my
aunt's house or something figure it out
what uh
well why don't you guys just go i love
belina looks like she's gonna freeze to
death
i'm good with this coat it's it's do
it's doing the job i'm just not used to
this
oh my god
she'll we'll appreciate california when
we come back so it's all good
all right well
what happened you i expected abe to do
some black friday shopping because i
expected just in detroit for to be a
little wild
yeah well it started with a lot of
fights at thanksgiving dinner between me
and my family and i really want to do
with my cousin because he's the
character
what fights
political fights what was the topics
everything
uh covid
uh
kyle rittenhouse all that oh my goodness
[ __ ] you guys really hit all those
topics huh
yeah and then my mom was asking me she's
like oh i've seen you guys have a new
show like a political show and so i was
showing her the last episode of
leftovers and like when i put it on uh i
cast my phone and it was like at the
part where you guys were doing the
scenario the thanksgiving dinner
scenario
which i thought was fine but once i
started playing that like my cousin like
didn't really got in my face then uh
ethan klein is is
damaging everything making it all worse
wait you're your cousin tim paul
nobody's name is tim one of them oh
you know flaming okay so
so he saw what we were saying and he
didn't like it
he's uh he thought like i was just
trying to
throw some extra shade at him because
like
the the hillbilly impersonation that you
were doing was pretty much the arguments
not all of them but they were along the
same you know line of thought as some of
the things he was saying so
yeah
pretty good though
love says it's 23 degrees in sweden yeah
but i bet your heater works bro
no
i don't wanna
one uh step up a b but we don't have any
18 miles
don't stop
are you serious seriously how can you
live in sweden and not have a heater
that doesn't make any sense
well we don't well
i mean
i don't know
is i just have my pc in my room and it
just
that
all of his uh bitcoin mining is uh doing
the job
giving off bro
and you're just wearing a hoodie
something doesn't add up
i'm not lying dude
you don't have like one of those units
like in new york where it's built into
the building
well first of all we have no air heating
we all know the only thing we have is
like electric uh elements or what no
yeah what's it called like space heater
yeah
just air like
yeah they just get hot like under the
window whatever those are called space
heater
i don't know if that's what it's called
honestly but yeah
so is that on
no
i i don't
i want to say that i don't believe you
how can you sit we turn the swede in
winter you say it's 23 degrees and
there's no heater how does that make
sense people would not that i ain't even
cold dude are you claiming the guy who's
forced five pairs of sunglasses is just
saying that for attention
with the clout theory
the cloud raider is going off the cloud
raiders going off on a b love do you
have a response i might really start
selling
should i like show you outside it's like
snow snow and stuff no me and me
we're on the same heaters right there
yeah
and this would be green if it was on
you so you're not cold you have a hoodie
with your sleeves up
yeah
check this out so you think you're just
adjusted you've got that swedish viking
blood you're more adjusted to the you
know what his blood's doing
what the hell was that
that was uh
those people
what in god's name are you trying to
show us dude
i just accidentally showed that i didn't
need to do that
all right i don't know why that was all
in the background
all right thank you love i think you
need a heater bro i don't care that
you're not good i like it like it cold
so uh he's calling you out ab and lena
you're saying you are wusses
i guess so i need some of that swedish
blood
that's not what i'm saying
i'm on your guys's side
i'm i'd be freezing my tits off man
okay against titties titties well okay
let's let's watch so so you so what
happened you guys were planning on going
black friday shopping your cousin tim is
is conservative he's like is he queuing
on he's anti-vaxx
my cousin tim is so weird he's like this
does it for i don't know he just likes
to argue that's all it is he's not
really contrarian
yeah i've seen that
right now rebel without a cause
okay so so you guys had some bitter
disagreements and then black friday got
cancelled
yeah well also none of the stores opened
at midnight here either which is what
they used to do which is why you guys
probably went on thursday in the past
because we used to go after thanksgiving
dinner as well like super late at night
the malls would like open uh late but
this year everything was 5 a.m
so yeah we tried but we just uh argued
back and forth i got some footage a
little bit but then he left with my
memory card in his car and he's legit
have not answered me since oh my god
wow shout out cousin tim
shut up should he call in the show i
don't want to talk to him
if if if i could trust him to be live
for 30 seconds or or more i swear he
would be like grade a wack pack
material but yeah
maybe on off the rails or something but
i'm afraid to have him be live you think
he'd say something racist or something
he's got some screws loose
i don't know how to explain it but
lena is he's speaking truth
he is
yes i love tim but he does he has some
screws list
and he's not offended you guys saying
that either i'm assuming
no guy has like no social media and it's
not because he's like some conspiracy
theories or anything he just i don't
know he just
he's always his cousin tim what can you
say yeah let's have him call into off
the rails i want to talk to i want to
interrogate him
yeah he's interesting dude the guy is
worth a couple million and wears the
same exact thing every day for like two
or three years wait how'd this guy make
the money
uh his father he just inherited it yeah
well that's nice
nice to be here i still have that
picture set up on on lovebottom
there we go
go ahead i don't see anything
it's on love screen
[Laughter]
when did you set that up
well we had it for what segment was it i
set this up do you remember it was like
a roommate story
yeah we like rescheduled and then like
when i tried to resay it's like all over
the place because i didn't have love
with me who was like my my elliot for
the story
yeah all right well can't wait to talk
to him by the way shout outs to the
penguins uh
who are
habitating your neighborhood
all right let's play the black friday uh
segment shall we
yeah so
uh cam and i went out and tried to find
some uh people to talk to who were
waiting in line for did you guys say
you're gonna buy me an xbox or something
that was originally
something we were thinking about getting
in line with everybody camped out and uh
talked to some characters so that's what
we attempted to do okay that's the goal
let's see what happens doesn't sound
like i'm getting an xbox this year maybe
next year
all right let's watch it
all right folks we're out here it's
black friday we're looking for some
deals we're looking for some crazy lines
some doorbuster sales i'm here with
cameron cameron what do you got to say
hey and thank you very much for inviting
me out and uh filming you tonight i'm
very excited to be out here with you
your great friend and i'm just happy to
be here with you man that's very sweet
of you to say black friday ladies and
gentlemen let's see what we can find and
it's officially 1201 black friday has
started as you can see the people
are
i'm sure they're on their way they might
be closed i'm not really sure what
that's about actually maybe it's a fake
out for the initial wave otherwise it'll
just get you know too chaotic so it's
probably a good call to make it seem
like this store is closed
we're here at gamestop where black
friday deals are going crazy the lines
are insane out here though don't pan
that way don't pan that way i don't even
know what to do with myself here the
xboxes are flying off the shelves
hey uh ian what are you doing there look
at it says black friday sale inside of
it black friday sale right there we will
find a black friday deal
i'm gonna find the deal we're here at
best buy where things got a little out
of control they had to put up security
barriers because people were people were
breaking in the police have been called
because these deals should be illegal
i'm assuming that all of the shoppers
are loaded up in that car
um
sort of a clown car situation there must
have been thousands of shoppers here
stuffed inside of that vehicle what
happened to camping out pissing and
[ __ ] in a gatorade bottle for a deal
on a panasonic television listen here
jack this is flying off the shelves here
in the parking lot i got the shoes
sometimes wear shoes in the pool mac
and that's that black friday forever
we're gonna find a deal dude nothing is
open nobody's out we're gonna find a
deal everybody loves amazon shut the
[ __ ] up cam dude jeff bezos took over
no goddamn line
find a deal best buy
go to best buy i just googled it it's
closed
get a deal on a body bag i googled it
black friday doorbuster body bag cameron
try it doorbuster deal at cnn maybe no
no line we're here we are driving in the
biggest shopping center in la it's
completely dead
they've literally put up barbed wire to
keep us out the berlin wall of shopping
look at the electric bill on these
lights and you're not allowed in it's 1
30. the shoppers are on their way
actually they probably took a big nap
all that turkey they earlier
yeah i think we should start heading
back
come on man i'm tired from the turkey is
there a black friday deal on unwanted
opinions from camera people because i'm
getting doorbusters on that do you think
they got black friday deals at citibank
one dollar will get you four quarters i
got a lead on a panasonic 60 inch it's
just it's just another 10 miles down
this way i got these leaves dude you've
been driving this whole time there's no
lead there's i've i heard i heard a good
thing about a washer dryer combo it's
down this way about another 15 35 miles
i don't know how you're getting i've got
leads cam
i've got leads okay can you just let me
out i'll call uber home you know what
did you just uh you just lock the door
on me don't worry about it okay you're
the camera guy so film and shut the [ __ ]
up i got a lead on an xbox series x it's
just another maybe 75 80 miles down the
way it's not that big we'll get you home
we'll get you home i don't like the way
your eyes are looking we'll get you home
kim we'll get you home
let's get can't jump
i'm gonna get a deal
i'm gonna find a deal
i'm gonna find a deal
black friday
black friday we will find a deal
regardless of what happens cameron's
life depends on it and this has gone too
far man i i gotta call love he's the
only one awake right now hey what's up i
need your help dude ian's going crazy is
that snow are you outside
you're eating snow fika that's kind of
weird love if i don't make it out
tonight just know what happened tell
tell the crew what happened all right
you know what that's enough of that
starbucks black friday you guys got
black friday nail salon black friday
does anybody have black friday
like friday
black friday
metro t-mobile black friday deal
this is what i think maybe i'm wrong and
maybe i did friday what is happening to
america and what the what the freak
it's appalling it's disgusting it's an
american tradition
been defiled frankly
is it
was their sales just like they did them
at like five in the morning or something
uh well i think that's what happened
best buy hours said five a.m but i think
it's all just online mostly no no one
wants to go out and nobody wants to do
that midnight anymore with the panty
going on the panty yeah
wow that's such so sad though i think
like the in-person demand is probably
gone
so usually people don't have to wait
that long usually we would see by now
the videos of people are trampling on
each other yeah there's no there's been
no fatalities
come on man
dude you give a little thing you take a
little life
that's the order that's how
thanksgiving's supposed to go in america
that
is how thanksgiving went the first time
also
yeah exactly
the uh right give a little bit that's
how it goes
kill some people
okay well so did anybody here actually
buy anything on black friday
sam and i are deciding on what we want
let's go i picked up uh a couple of um
hot new shirts at h3h3shop.com
new holiday merch drop available now
incidentally not on sale but
it is still there that's a good plug dan
h3h3 shop the christmas uh wait yeah
hold on hold on
just
just uh you know wait why would we keep
it fifty exactly presents is missing
here oh yeah
here i got it
there we go can i tell you something me
and i were driving in the car to my
parents house on thanksgiving and i was
listening to like a classic rock
playlist and clyden's klein water came
on uh-huh and i was driving and i was
like oh bro this is bad juju did you get
there safely yeah are you okay i did but
i skipped i skipped this song
if i listen to this too long we're gonna
crash
i think on that halloween episode we i i
i'm gonna go out on the limb and say we
lifted the curse i think i think the
curse is done yeah but i still had a
super supernatural rea or a super
stitious reaction to it
i was like oh buddy
can't [ __ ] with the klein water
[Laughter]
so anyway
um
h3shop.com our christmas collection all
profits
that come from this are going directly
to the crew
which is really exciting guys so
again every purchase goes directly 100
to support to support the gank whoa
[Laughter]
good job
what did he jump i didn't see that i let
him down oh okay got it
yeah so um this one was made by dan's
girlfriend that's right that's right
it's good it's so nice um the
advent calendar yeah not the nativity
scene yeah
um the shredi yeti and freddy
or shreddy alfredo freddy alfredy and
the yeti
um
cute we have the
nice classic peace and love
oh they did me like
is that what's going on yeah this is a
or we all look like ringo
this is a serious message to everybody
cam our very own cam made this one and i
love it so much we're all snowmen
it's so sick you guys
shout outs to cam
for that masterpiece and just your
classic snowflake
snowflakes here exactly that's right
so there you have it h3h3shop.com
you can get them by christmas
uh and it all supports the crew which is
awesome
uh let's thank our sponsor
got a lot to get to today by the way
great segment ian that was so good yes
well done thank you thank you okay you
went out there you went out there in the
middle of the [ __ ] night
now did you let did you expect to find
people or
we we went out because i was like oh
we're we'll we will talk to people and
why not that was the truth yeah the goal
was to like interview people that were
crazy enough to go out there and turns
out
the only people crazy enough to be out
there was the end and we pulled up and
we were like what the hell are we gonna
film right now okay that's exactly what
happened to us
yeah
we were the only ones yeah we were just
behind the car well that was years ago
it was years ago yeah i mean they were
still doing this
no nothing maybe santa cruz just too
small of a town to do the midnight [ __ ]
oh maybe
it's possible
or you went on the wrong night
it could have
also possible could have been the wrong
day all right let's thank honey
speaking of black friday who needs black
friday when you got honey
we all
it's almost like sinister i'm not sure
that's the tune no it's like a it's like
a surf vibe we're like we're driving
down uh pch right now
it sounds like you're like oding on
heroin or something that's what it
sounds like
it's like a fear and loathing but
in reality you guys got scammed let's
get a little more upbeat uh i mean zach
plays this one all the time this is in
he he instructed me where his um here
this is sabbath style it's labeled as
okay well let's save that one well
all right here we go we out shop online
and we've seen that promo code field
taunt us at checkout but thanks to honey
manual searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds
to your cart honey supports over 30 000
stores online ranging from tech gaming
beauty products popular fashion brands
and even food delivery
speaking with was this one of your epic
saves oh this is another
postmate save what 12 bucks off yeah
that's the one i sent you right yep see
i was i was i was so surprised i was
just ordering on the computer i usually
do it on the phone but that's just beat
up like what
totally didn't even expect anything to
come up and this happened wow that
that's
that's what i'm saying that's the
that's the power
and uh it's free and it's super easy to
use it's kind of hard to even believe
it's real imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites when you check
out the honey button drops down all you
have to do is click apply coupon wait a
few seconds honey searches for coupons
you can find for that site if honey
finds a working coupon you'll watch the
price drop magically honey has found
it's over 17 million members over two
billion dollars in savings so if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's literally free installs in a few
seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast
we use it we love it get honey for free
at joinhoney.com
h3ad that's join honey.com
h38d thank you thank you to honey
yes
yes yes queen
what is this vin diesel happy
thanksgiving message
this is awesome oh this is a fresh vin
diesel post yeah my boy
cooking up a storm coming up a storm
he's about to hit on the shot
thanksgiving's on on
super
very happy thanksgiving so close
thanksgivings on i like that
super super super good super foods and
yeah
wow
wow get it get it get it
[Music]
did you see the
the vin diesel impersonators chanting oh
i did but i never showed it yeah
somebody had like a vin diesel
impersonator get together bruh
have you seen this no it's pretty fever
dreamy
it's awesome catapulted to one of my
favorites while you find that yeah you
know there was this amazing teddy fresh
story and actually it's you're going to
like it ela because
it's what we've always wanted is that
people who are not
fans of ours buying teddy fresh that's
the dream right
well here it is and we're in uh living
proof
embarrassing teddy fresh story from the
subreddit
basically i was at work
when a super cute customer came in
wearing teddy fresh
so i said i liked her hoodie and she
said thanks and we had a nice chat
then she asked me where the bathroom was
i assumed she watched the podcast
so i said i don't use the bathroom i
usually just pee in my basement
face went blank so i said you know when
your wife goes out for pizza without you
so you just pee in the basement out of
spite
literally no reaction from her i was so
embarrassed i did explain it but i blew
my chances 100 percent how amazing is
that
that's the best
that is amazing i mean dude that's a
bold statement even if you're assuming
they're
yeah you just peed it's okay
a member in the chat just uh
sent a super chat thing that's my
embarrassing story oh my god they're
watching right now so shout out shout
out shout out
i love that story
you took a risk
you took a risk and then pay off
sometimes you take risks and they do pay
off
if she was a fan she would have loved it
yeah
what the hell oh my god
that's been diesel olivia just sent this
looks like a wallace wallace what the
hell
same angle too
play new conspiracy theory unlocked he's
entirely made of clay
and diesel's made of clay there's no
such thing as a coincidence there's no
such thing as vin diesel
talk to me baby that uh a b sent that um
uh
family chant
oh thank you right above that yes so um
for people who are joining and wondering
why i'm in the bed
we said in the beginning but it's
because i have back pain and it's hard
for me to sit in like a regular chair
right now for
for a long time we set up a uh
we set up a bed first
she could be pros she could be lying
down yeah how's that feel is it okay it
is yeah yeah that's good alfredo's still
up there with you yeah he's right
against my back thank you that's perfect
legend shredder's regretting it he wants
to come back up
well what can i do i'm trying to do a
show i can't be lifting you up and
putting you down all day shredder
gotta make up your mind
all right here is a vin diesel
gathering of the mines
bohemian grove family family oh my god
[Music]
family family family family family still
weird
family family family family family it's
like different levels of looking like
him yeah this guy's the star yeah run
he's like the most and then they're like
ten percent less than this guy's black i
mean he's not even the right
pink color
i don't know if that matters but i mean
probably
if you're a look like
if a black dude showed up if i ordered a
vin diesel look-alike
vin diesel is uh half black you know
that he is oh my god
oh are you sure
wait his adopted father is
african-american okay
just like the quartering
wait yeah just like the quartering well
that might be gay too they have the same
origin story
that's very interesting there's nothing
talk to me baby find these will be like
brie larson talk to me
family family we should make this a
sound bite for sure
what was this made for
i think this is like a really expensive
cameo
[Music]
well some of these guys are not even
trying like there's an old guy a black
family family the family
has dedicated his whole life pretty much
to
um being vin diesel it's pretty funny i
follow him on instagram okay so he'd be
happy to say that i'm like i said he's
the premier of indeed
yeah it's like short vin diesel well
it's not that tall is he
well this dude is super short let's see
the diesel height oh he's six foot
jump wait
the rock is six five that's pretty it's
pretty tall
there you go
clay face
play diesel
oh thank you i got his uh
love sent his page the vin diesel look
like this is great this is a interesting
rabbit hole to go down
yeah so he's got 50 000 followers
certainly
a dedicated fan base there
working out as part of my lifestyle been
doing it for 20 years follow me and i
will follow back oh like share for share
like or like follow
get that following
let's see
so he's posted this family family family
oh it's a new angle oh
is this his thing
yeah i think so yeah
well he organized this
okay interesting that was interesting
man so i guarantee you a few of these
guys have no idea what they're doing
right now
they're just hella confused
so they're going for a world record
family how many times they say it they
said 100 at the top no they can go
longer than that family family family
family
i think that guy's my favorite we're
just zooming in
i'm waiting to get to 100.
you know
let's see what's there
family family
whoa they didn't say no
they didn't save don just time yeah
family family this is [ __ ] crazy dude
what is this guy so here he is he got a
whole photo shoot with all of his goons
i don't have friends i got family
[Music]
i don't have a friend
i don't want friends
i only got family
here let's see what this guy's up to
cars like this are eternal cars like
this you take care of them
[Music]
vin wears sleeves
i think he'll die before he'll watch
slaves oh here he is with david dubrick
of course
no just close up i guess in lieu of
meeting the real vin diesel he's not
famine us for that
mother of god just play audio
behind the scenes with david we forgot
the car was in reverse
i missed the mark with that one
is he exposing him
oh my god he exposed this idiot
no just close up on the cheers did he
hit something it sounds like he sounded
like it yeah
and then panda me driving away three two
[Music]
yeah still [ __ ] his car up
dumb ass
i'm fascinated by this rabbit hole
we gotta get him if i mean if if uh
david duber gets him we gotta get him
sure
somebody contact this man
i wonder if he'd be down to to reenact
the creepy interview
oh my god you think he would do that
against the family oh that might be that
is a little disrespectful to talk to me
baby it's a little disrespectful to the
to the real vin
what if he co-hosted an episode of off
the rails with me where he just did it
uh vin diesel memes that'd be [ __ ]
fun
talk to me baby
live sound bites
that's an idea i'm into it let's
concentrate let's get a whole lot of sun
bites i like that
so who uh
who's in charge or that's usually zach
make sure he gets on that sure next week
well love you said you did he said
follow for follow you follow him does he
follow you
liar
what's the liar
you're one family i was going to say
that's our end love should never betray
your family oh that's fine long time
fantastic you have to call him i don't
know when he comes on the show
wow
yeah we have to confirm hold on follow
him from the podcast and message him
love
and say will you be our family on the
show i'll pay him whatever he wants
whatever he wants name any number
any number you got it love
yeah i'm on it all right thank you
duber
dubrick
dubrick i
so we made a comment about nicocado
saying i was ugly which obviously was
hyperbole he was being nice about it
yeah i was just you know
hyperbole okay
you ever heard of it
don't sue me ryan cavanaugh he's trying
to sue me for hyperbole
uh
little little uh
so he made a whole reaction video to me
right
let's watch it
did he also say do we have a possible
end to getting him on the show who was
talking to him no those were words that
he said in the video oh
yeah you'll see it all when you're when
you watch i thought god damn i i
genuinely i really want him on the show
so i don't know
well he lays down his terms let's watch
i'll i'll do anything that's it
it took him 20 minutes to get to it what
the [ __ ] we're 20 minutes into this [ __ ]
reacting to ethan h3 video about me
mukbang this thing 2012.
[Music]
see you there at five love
all right dude
i'll buy you some pizza can we get some
it's my cheat day too
there it is
what is happening to my life by the way
i'm reacting to reacting people who sit
and react to people
i've
i don't know what it is is this just the
time of year where everyone just like
makes videos about me
and just watches i don't well you know
it's not judge yet because i don't know
i've been having like a good week okay
and i didn't need anything today
is this the right time stamp
yeah
um
sent it uh from our other director beat
it over yeah
olivia did the write-up but this is just
where he starts talking
yeah copy over the whole right up into
the uh into the dock
yes so um
ela said what that's a lot of food what
a shot yeah this is what is continent i
don't know if you're how familiar you
are i'm not
he started as a super skinny vegan yeah
and then he just went beast mode
and uh now he does gaping
anal porn
i do literally i mean i'm not joking i
mean i saw escaping [ __ ] when we
talked about him
uh it's pretty wild i mean shout outs i
guess
a thousand calorie doughnut calories is
this is this like um
i have a genuine question and forgive me
if it's insensitive or something but
what is that is this
like glorifying eating disorder
i don't know there's like a blurry line
with because some
creators a lot when i was a kid support
him and some creators put critical
videos out so
i don't know well i like him as a person
he seems charming and nice and whatever
i again i say that with have not oh
sorry if he's like you know say that
with no knowledge whatsoever exactly
okay
you know [ __ ] dude i can't say anything
about anyone anymore let's see you guys
all wonder why i talk [ __ ] on everyone
that's why you're safer if you just talk
[ __ ] it's true it's yeah it's actually
much safer it's like everyone just like
everyone out there when you like someone
you put your ass out for people to be
like i can't believe you woke up
very true tell me tell me about it
[Laughter]
yeah you like me that's the biggest risk
yeah
who are you kidding huh oh i guess he
doesn't
well
to me looking at this this is a little
wild bro like does anyone need to see
this [ __ ] yeah i watch these videos you
do i don't
just like mooc bongs are a thing i must
i probably am saying that wrong but like
i've been watching them forever just
because
it's something that some people like
some people listen to asmr i enjoy
watching mukbang why
i don't know
do you eat and watch it it depends
sometimes i'll just watch it
is it like a
uh forgive me if this is too personal
you don't have to answer but
is it help with like if you have eating
issues
yeah i think for different people it
like
i'm sure that watching something like
this would trigger
or like some people say hello or the
opposite when i watch it i feel like oh
my god i'm eating so much fun food you
know
so it either will fill that craving or
like trigger okay so it has something to
do with some kind of trigger
for or against
yeah
i don't know personally for me i just
feel like i'm indulging in like good
food
you feel like you're eating the food
they're eating or like just watching
them do it it's like
that food looks so good
and you don't want to eat it yourself
you just get some pleasure from watching
them eat it yeah and obviously he's he's
very entertaining yeah he's entertaining
i get that
like i don't really watch the people who
don't speak and eat
right
it smells like apples where's the audio
i turned it down because you guys were
talking about
and i moved all the time
they had the uh the con pile on their
menu i thought that's that's what you
were able to get but oh that's just not
good i guess it's like
i mean they know what they're doing is
not healthy so it's not like a surprise
that they know eating 100 donuts
isn't gonna make you live forever
um
but i guess it's almost like watching an
addict like shoot up
and then you're like oh this helps me
with my addiction
maybe it's entertainment for some people
i'm just trying to is do a value
judgment on
the therapy aspect
of like somebody basically killing
themselves
for
is that
that's certainly an argument people make
but another argument would be like it's
their oh
what's that
what love
sorry ah the
delay is kind of missing but i think
this is kind of comparable with the
eugenia cooney stuff
right just the other side of the goal so
gina cooney is this girl who's anorexic
and
super anorexic and i guess a lot of
people say you know
uh
it's she she people say she's enabling
more anorexia by being on the platform
is that what you mean luck
oh no i just think it's comparable i
think if you think one is bad i think
you should think the other one is kind
of bad
personally i don't think they should be
removed from the platform that seems
kind of crazy but
just acknowledge the fact that it's
probably kind of similar yeah i think
that's a good comparison
[Music]
but i get like i'm not i'm not trying to
quantify like the therapy aspect or the
enjoyment people get out of it i'm just
saying like is it ethical
to watch an addict kill themselves
i mean again they're everybody's
consenting here nothing's being done
right they're choosing to put this
content yeah
i don't know i've already lost count
though they're counting you please count
for us yeah y'all count because i forgot
and tell us at the at the end of this
show how many of these don't
watching and she's gonna tell us
10 000 calories worth
you ate what
what that's only like three of those
doughnuts
she was gonna give this to her roommate
susan if susan
nice shirt
yes so
um
i kind of want to count the donuts but
okay let's not [ __ ] watch that
because let's not do that anyway here he
is a little bat a crash course on
nickacado
but can you imagine doing like gaping
porn on that diet
um
[Music]
can you imagine
everybody poops
not like him that kind of [ __ ] like you
do i guarantee it his shits do not look
like yours i [ __ ] promise you that
big massive dumps
i don't know
you don't know i mean well when you eat
what does it matter when you poops are
gross well i'm saying like vegan people
can have really gross poop too
no but i'm just saying the volume like
you've got to clean it all out if you're
going to participate in
back door activities usually
yeah so
this is your questions i want to ask him
and this is i think fascinating
what i'm thinking is pizza with french
fries topped with ranch
and also if you could stomp your foot on
it
[Applause]
[Music]
that one got a lot of views people are
interested in the nicocado story
in fact cam we could probably add him to
the thumbnail
we should
are you looking at me well yeah i am
looking at you but uh giving a note to
uh cam thank you
guys
he's under eating
she's funny
because i'm fat
on it
[Applause]
all right let's move on we got so much
to get to guys
he's under eating i'm sorry but that is
funny
he's not eating sufficient calorie
intake
when you start having
visions like that when they go to the
extreme it means you're not eating
enough food and trust me you turn it up
they happen to know
and here's here's a little um a little
something for you so i obviously am a
little overweight it's mostly water
retention
just a little i identify as fluffy as
well as skinny
and um the heavier i get of water
i've noticed that i have to eat more to
keep my metabolism high right so i'm
actually not even that fat because i
should be i should be like 600 pounds
based on how much i've eaten over the
past five years but i'm not because i'm
behind my metabolism i've only gained
200.
right
speaking of which she's getting me
hungry sam you're ordering food right
yeah
where are you getting from
dealer's choice eli you have an opinion
go ahead you talk to amongst yourself in
discord
by the way did you see nick ocado called
me ugly
he didn't say you're ugly didn't he i
heard what he said
lies
excuse me you know who i am
here it is by the way wouldn't it be an
interesting interview like i
i kind of want to
i don't know anything about it i mean
the guy's story and everything is
what is this
he started as this vegan
yeah super skinny
him and his husband or boyfriend i don't
know if they're married
and then
over time they started doing these
movings and i guess apparently it took
off for him
and now they're like both massive i like
how he puts his hands out to here
i'm literally the same size as you
let's
let's let's first of all
okay i
i am large but come on now
not as fat as you [ __ ]
pretty funny
we're both bad guys who know they're fat
come on
there's camaraderie here
don't call me fat fatty
fat fatty
i have more water weight than you [ __ ]
you saw meat canyons
horrible hit pc it's so quiet what can
we do about this
what
the video is quiet i can't hear it very
well
okay i'll turn it up all right it's
pretty loud
not for me okay
just turn up my monitor all right are
you doubting that i can't yeah well a
little bit it's quite loud well why
would i lie to you about not being able
to hear well all right
go for it i'm not trying to do a ruse on
you i genuinely just want to hear it
on me making me out to here i'm not even
that fat
i i'm literally probably within 20 30
pounds away from him and now it's
getting
now it's getting
too loud
okay well i feel like you're trying to
like i just turned it up with one notch
because it was like gradually getting
louder did you hear that eva
um okay let's i won't include you in
this
sound rivalry
most likely well i'm also six foot one
so i don't know how tall he is either
but i mean just looking at him if we
were sitting side by side we would look
like a similar statue
you gotta come into the show because
i'm pretty sure i could fit three of me
and you
maybe not three
maybe one point five maybe two bribe
ethan climb like this
he's just massive he's just
it's just everyone's been doing this
lately let me show you
i'm not that fat
i identify as skinny that's my identity
if you choose not to respect my identity
that's you see what i'm saying this guy
is such a character
so major trick survives right there
you got trisha vibes well he used to
idolize her they had some crazy beef
where oh really where he came out to
meet her for a collab and she ghosted
him
and made him seem like a stalker it
seems like super messed up i want to
talk to him about that too he got mad at
me because i said like offhand when i
was telling the story that he he asked
her to collab but really she tweeted at
him so she asked him to collab
because she well she really loved the
violin cover of her song that he did for
her
i remember she commented something
really beautiful on that video like
thank you so much for this and then
apparently she tweeted at him and then
he said yes and then was ghosted
she came out to la and then she stopped
answering his calls
and he's like what the [ __ ]
didn't he poop on her couch yo what
that's what people were saying i don't
remember this motherfucker's like
popping from seinfeld he'd be [ __ ]
on people's couches
that's what i'm saying bro
you you that diet of yours is gonna
you're gonna be leaving poops on couches
i'm not at that stage yet my friend
i live for the chaos of it all [ __ ]
on couch well i'll tell you what nick
i'm dying for you to come on the podcast
i'll do whatever it takes but you are
not allowed to sit on any of our
furniture
it means it's true
so respect it
all right you can buy this by the way
link down below it's just
waterweight.com
okay am i even wait wait is that really
his domain
it's justwaterweight.com
holy [ __ ] dude this guy's [ __ ]
awesome he's literally like feeder yeah
that's what he's doing
whether or not
that is him or not he's playing it
in a theatrical way to talk to him i
need him here now and by the way
he's like those you know those musicians
do magicians that dedicate their life to
the magic and so they like cut off their
arm or something so they can do one
trick better
he's that
right
he's the magician who does mukbangs
every day
he probably hates food he was a skinny
vegan he could he probably hates fast
food
it's just dedicated
do you see how much i love you nick come
i'm a stan basically
let's continue this is great i love it
i love it
not that here let me show you
oh that's interesting stupid
i'm not that fat
i literally look like a regular american
well that's true
down the street you wouldn't you
wouldn't even be like oh my god he's so
bad oh my gosh
like honestly
if i was going in my shopping cart
yeah
he'd have nothing to say
you want to be like he's just
massive he's
[Music]
ouch my legs
so strike one spreading rumors spreading
lies he's worse than my scale
my skin
he lies on me i mean come on
i mean i love how he slides the food up
like that
is a standing desk that he has that he
that's literally
that is awesome man
or maybe it's not even just the fact
that it it's just i think it's a tray
for yeah it's like for fat people
is that heart
thing yeah it's like if you can't move
and you're like dinner time
do you say gin and tonic i said dinner
time oh
interesting
i have one at my bedside that's how i
know about it
like look at your own man he's my size
okay eli you weigh in he just called you
out am i the size of nick i'm alfredo i
mean
maybe not identical but i get his point
you're not you guys are not far off are
you [ __ ] serious not far off i think
you think i eat like this
no you don't eat like that but i'm not
far off
it's gone that far huh
i mean anybody else i don't know i could
take it it's not that far off it's not
far off i'm sorry
i mean he's bigger than you but not by
like a lot it's not like enough for you
he's not okay you keep pointing to the
amount that he's eating that's
irrelevant we're not talking about how
much he eats when you come out here
we're going shirtless and doing a side
by side okay
i'm telling you this is [ __ ] i think
he's bigger than you but over 100 pounds
on them no i don't think so
yes well you're solar go ahead love
please speak up
he's at least 30 percent heavier than
you 30 percent i don't know well
he said you guys are like maybe 20 30. i
would say 50
50 how much do you think he went 50
i think he's like 350 probably
here
simple google search says
300 i mean i don't know how accurate
that is but
yeah gila come on yeah okay i mean it's
right
it's just water work okay just come on
you uh
okay don't be dirty like that
he's still pretty mobile though he's got
energy yeah can't deny that he's got
locked down with all those [ __ ]
galleries he thinks yeah
he's got so much energy
he's ready to go to the outer space with
it
on heidi
wake up
he's calling how you talking to me wait
what does that mean he called you her
heidi he doesn't know her name
he said hilda
and then he asks siri to look up um
something about you and he calls you
heidi klump
oh that's rude
he doesn't know her name i'm kidding i
don't care okay see now i'm getting
angry
and we're just literally starting people
no
it's just
i mean it's just
lies
yeah yeah i i i i don't want to put out
the wrong like um chat would like an
interview with but i i actually i just
find him actually funny and interesting
wait he said he's six one
a b is coming out saying he's five eight
so i'm five eleven and this guy's got a
hundred hundy on me
come on now don't do me dirty like that
y'all you all hurt my feelings on this
day you said you could take it i'm just
kidding it didn't
i just didn't want i just i just you
were begging for a comparison you guys
really [ __ ] hate me
fat phobia in this i'm just kidding i
don't care
i'm kidding
what did i do not you me and oh no don't
be mad at them i'm just kidding guys
they were telling me the truth i asked
for they're mad at us
i demanded they tell me it's funny we're
all doing comedy here we're all
entertaining
no anger directed at eel and dan right
now stop
the only anger that should be directed
is that nickacado who needs to be on
this show
i'm ready to start this feud
oh
but i think
that you're offended by ela and dan the
way that um nick was offended by you
yes
you guys share that and that's why nick
you should come on the show and talk to
ethan about the way you feel i'll fly
you out first class bro i'll do it in
fact i'll even buy you two seats because
your fat ass probably needs to see it's
even first class he actually
said that in his video oh there you go
you'll see that coming up
he was like a super fan of hers and then
he went to meet her in l.a and she like
flaked on him
and they turned into this huge beef
right
so what happened uh i'm sorry i was
looking at something
he said he said in a previous video he's
339 so yeah he has 100 pounds on me and
he's three inches shorter
it's hard to distinguish what's trolling
what is it that [ __ ] weighs 350
that ain't no trolling
the only thing it is is rolling because
he's like a ball
thank you he looked much bigger in that
beach video than he did each video is
different than when he stood up in this
video and was standing to the side that
didn't look that didn't look like god
was hanging out of his shirt yeah but
there's different body types
you know like i gotta lose weight if
y'all think i've got that nico caught a
body
[Music]
[Music]
he would just go who are you
yeah yeah
fair enough
these people
who are you that's a b
heartthrob who are you
legend
was that right he looks like a pirate
this is him when he started youtube oh
crazy i
watched him from
then from when he was in vega so i was
saying i think he'd be an interesting
person to interview who are you lady
who is this
lady
i've been watching him since that the
beginning who are you
who are you
again i'm just he's she's a fan nick
geez you could be a little [ __ ] up
was that a problem yeah it made me so
sad
but it's fine
who are you
a fan literally a fan like i was just
like giving all praise also we called
you a pirate a.b what do you think about
that
i wasn't sure what he meant by that but
i think because my mustache was like
super thin that that's he was a friend
of jack sparrow
i hope that's what he meant that's the
sparrow a little dude ethnically uh
uh ambiguous
yeah i'll take it well jack well
obviously johnny depp is just a white
dude
but
i think you meant the
maybe the beard
what did we decide on on food by the way
in honor of nicocado um
come on guys nico cotto's here we gotta
order food in honor of him in the chat
veggie grill
veggie grill yeah
is that okay with you
whatever you like i guess technically
i'm fine with that
technically what's the technical
you know what's my problem with veggie
girl it's just a little dry
that's true you could sauce it up you
could just toss some sauce on that bad
boy it's always just very dry i'm like
menacino's better
mendoza screwed us last time though
how so they were the ones that they
never delivered it was last friday oh
they just fell they bailed yeah that
wasn't that was a hard day for us
but then we ended up getting it they
were redeemed
did they redeem oh we did get it
together cam's requesting buffalo
chicken calzone dude this guy is
obsessed where do you are you guys aware
of this yeah cam where do you even get a
calzone and we'll buy one
you tell me where the [ __ ] we buy
buffalo chicken calzone
it's not a thing that people make on a
regular basis like yeah you got to come
with uh
with a game plan if you're going to
order if you want us to get this guy was
this is cam's twitter feed i'm not
kidding this is oh let me see it's not
from today this is buffalo chicken
calzone
buffalo chicken ketchup
buffalo chicken with your buffalo
chicken buzzfeed food video and
who heard you cameron what is happening
here
actually cameron was uh uh he's
embarrassed to say and it's very tragic
but he was uh
essayed by a buffalo chicken calzone oh
okay ethan you started a whole thing
just so you know what i'm doing people
are gonna say that i see it i see it
happening in the chat wait what happened
they are gonna start saying that we are
mean to you oh
you know what no i like that because
it's always i'm mean to people
i like that please yeah i need a little
um
i need a little victim
points at least victim narrative yeah
can i get some victim points here yeah
you guys are mean to me please that's
right
here i can jump in and get canceled real
quick yes
no i'm just gonna say uh chat i don't
know if you guys know this but ethan and
eli are married and dan and ethan are
good friends and they work together i
think they know each other and how to
talk to each other a little bit better
than you guys sorry not to be a dick but
maybe why are you being such an [ __ ]
to the chat right now
no they're right no idea the victim
please i'm the victim and i'm sick of it
please post uh i want posts on the
subreddit saying that how much they
support me how much they love me how
much i give for this show i give
everything i'm here that day after
thanksgiving i could be in line on black
friday i'll give it to you and i get no
respect around here no love
i am the victim
all right i want 10 threads right now
two apology videos
and maybe you're fired
this is going to somehow land back on
you anyways ethan
somehow conversation
first of all we're only
judging based
on a video that was dan for the record
who played the godfather music yeah
zack's not here
um you asked we only saw this video i
said multiple times i don't know
anything about him so i don't know what
he looks like i don't know his full body
nicka cotto is tearing this family apart
so
i'm just making a guess to me it didn't
look far off sorry
i i already said guys i i for i wanted
her to say honestly i want to know what
they're honestly thinking
it's interesting
and i'm not offended trust me i mean
this is our vibe there are there are no
yes people in our circles
and it's not like my great
sometimes to my great right
pain and suffering right or no yes
well there's one but he's not here today
zach
oh yeah zach is kind of a yes man
that's true but we love him for that we
love him for it yeah but when you showed
him on the beach then it started to look
different like hey i don't know i'm just
judging basically first of all this
video is just showing shoulders and up
and then he was walking a little bit and
the shirt was too tight on him so i
can't be so pissed that everyone's angry
that
that's true that people i know i know
you guys are married and have a kid
together and live together but these
people you know they watch ethan they
they don't have they know the dynamic
yeah
yeah
zack's such a yes man i'd be like yo
should we go like um
i was thinking of maybe uh
you know
bombing the
easy
i was thinking about putting on like a
uh stick of tnt and going to a s
going to the mall putting on a vest of
explosive and going to the mall he's
like that's dope that's cool that sounds
great i'm i'm in
when i fired up his computer today uh
because i wanted to set up for the sound
bites or whatever i was greeted with
this i had no idea but it's just he just
killed her brain
he also has a joker card on his desk
that kath made for us
you guys think maybe he's overly
dedicated to the meme
maybe
i mean nobody would have ever seen this
if he wasn't unless that's just for him
that's for him that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah
that's good
that is good
definitely
all right so because cameron's so
obsessed i think we should get calzones
is that okay ela
what where do you even get that he's the
one who's been tweeting like a madman
about [ __ ] calzone
sorry you don't want to calzone nah well
she hates italian food
yeah hila's well known for hating
italian food
cam why don't you just buy yourself a
calzone you're not working calzone cam
cam get over here get over here you're
saying like you've been tweeting about
it for a month have you not bought
yourself a calzone am i the only
person that buys you food
dan i thought we agreed not to feed kim
that's true but i'm tired of hearing cam
have you eaten a calzone since you've
been here in l.a uh no i just i mean if
i'm being honest it's just like midnight
cravings and stuff so why don't you buy
yourself a calzone i just thought that
in the chat i'm just gonna get one on my
own this weekend
so
wow you fold it quick dude well hey
i'm just throwing it out there for a
suggestion i i wasn't married to the
idea or anything i'm i'm i'm game for
any free food tonight
cam go back to your closet no all right
bye guys get out of here don't stop i
don't like that joke maybe you're
canceled we love camp
no we all mean dan always make this joke
because any time we like someone will
send in the chat what does everyone want
to eat kim will be like can i have some
we're like yes cam you could eat then
after like months of doing that and he
like puts his hands out too like an
orphan so we kind of just made a joke
that we're we don't feed him anymore
yeah
yeah he's our little oliver
um
so back to nick which i'm enjoying a lot
but we need food if we're going to talk
about nick anymore so we all need to
decide we got calzones we got veggies
oh we're doing mando's done so give me
that turkey blt with extra bacon for uh
nick
okay for nick's sake
actually get me like five of them for
nick i'll have to eat all five
let's go
what's mukbang
here we go sacrifice for nick i feel
like my weight is under attack
and they are being fat phobic click the
link below to follow my patreon you'll
get exclusive weekly videos about my
life plus tons of mukbangs not allowed
on youtube link below
what in the [ __ ] was that
it's a little bumper this is really the
time and place for that
link below
bro come on
gotta work on that transition a little
bit oh wow a lot of dislikes
is that normal for his videos or people
just don't like me i think it they're
usually pretty split
sorry for no i think
it's disliked in
support of you oh really people are
actually mad at him
uh guys he's kidding i don't think he's
actually mad
well i don't know him though
me on his podcast
listen
ethan and hildy if you want me on your
podcast you need to fly me out there
because
and i only fly first class it's not
because i know he's kidding but done bro
you don't know me i spent six thousand
dollars on a scorpion chair
i'll fly you out first class i think i'm
really that important
it's because i don't fit in the seats
and i'm not even being funny i barely
even fit in first class coming here i'm
currently in las vegas i also need
payment for my time
fine because
i am very busy i post every single day
and
i just do so you need to find me there
first class seats
and some place to go answer our emails
how do we're trying to we've been trying
to contact him
done first class payment you want to get
all of it it's all done bro and but i'll
tell you what i'll have like i'll have
like a thousand chicken nuggets here on
the table waiting for you too i'll have
food ready
and food to eat shine bright like a
diamond i'm being totally serious by the
way this guy's content is so high level
he you see when he wouldn't use the
white balance
he does it to white balance his camera i
barely even start to adjust the uh
the iso or something i also need payment
for my time when it gets all blown out
because
i am very busy i post done bro say no
more
i just do so you need to find me there
and you better give me first class seats
and some place to go and food to eat
should i write like a diamond i've been
totally serious by the way can you send
what you saw like i just want to look at
it okay so if you want to know
apparently someone is saying wait they
still make videos together he said he's
in vegas that's super close too like don
dun dun bro easy
done
done
oh my god alfredo so cute what the hell
he's so
going on over precious
look at that
look at this guy cute
oh
my goodness oh my so sweet god
love him
well a lot so i don't know this is him
this is him when he started youtube oh
crazy i
watched him from them i mean how would
you like it if i made a video about
someone and said
this is his body
[Music]
let's just talk about it oh
he's like so big now
[Laughter]
i feel like i'm in middle school
this is not normal behavior
how or old either is what you're doing
so
40s
i'm not my 40s [ __ ]
my guys you're 40 years old 36. hey siri
how old is heidi
klump klein
lady klum is 48 years old that's not
what she looks like hey siri how old is
that from h3h3
okay i found this on the web for how old
is heidi from 8383
[Laughter]
okay you that's asian she's not asian
you are useless um she's useless
useless you guys useless i zoomed in on
it we're not
just going to interview you i love you
okay oh yes
because i'm looking for people i'm
really interested in that i think would
be yeah obviously i would just do it as
him as himself
oh my gosh stupid i don't know how to
hold this there's no uh
look how the freaking peasant they have
all these orange juice is doing a
wheelie like
even his phone is fat
you
thank you
they have literally little cheerleaders
in the back i love him
i love him i've been watching forever
talking about you very much for all
husbands well anyway i think he's
oh
your
interesting
that was beyond vile
toxic masculinity dan came back from the
bathroom without any
[Music]
photos from contact fans and he plays it
off like you guys are saying that his
body is gross
oh
well
probably because
maybe he's afraid to mention it because
he'll get i don't i don't know but
just for context oh i was really we're
not talking about history i really
wanted to see his reaction to the gaping
uh
reaction you want to see his gaping body
did you see that already
yes you did okay
look at them joking about my size
i mean i know i'm really big
i'm
ba well
looking at ethan we're probably the same
size no i'm not even that big i really
am
bang but i'm not big big it's mostly
water
look at them joking like ha ha ha ha ha
ha
it's just like is there more to watch uh
olivia or moon
is he
oh
[Music]
oh my gosh they all live in california
yeah oh my god
orlan threw a noodle at me
as if recently he's been more goofy
goofy like people are meaning on him
interview with me about
some nars anyway this is a meme
you may have
this is me saying
first class
payment
food a food voucher
yes yes yes yes yes i'm desperate
something that he did say that i made
sure to take note of was
he thinks that the entire
interview will just be about his weight
which he doesn't want so he was like
what what will you even interview me
about
i have many questions for him hear that
nick i have i want to talk to him as a
person what the whole thing is just you
know he just seems funny yeah he's funny
he's entertaining he's interesting i'm
fascinated by him i want to know about
you know
your whole life dude incredibly talented
entertainer
i also yes yeah yes
he has a lot to give and in fact we can
eat nuggies during the interview as to
come for you
and also me let's be honest okay
are you still a fan olivia
i don't know
really rob he got you huh no but it's
just i said super like appreciate
that i just
don't like what he had to say like i
appreciate what he does i don't
appreciate that he didn't like that i
was his fan
i think he's just doing [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i know there's something so weird seeing
people that you yeah like watch talk
about you it still hurts
no i'm not
i'm still a fan i'm not angry at all it
still hurts
you know what bro i'll even do a mukbang
with you
how about that
you come to our podcast and we can shoot
a mukbang together for your channel
how about that [ __ ]
i would love to watch that now that's
content
we'll see who can eat more
yeah i mean he said he you like your
belly look at look at heidi she's just
like
oh that's really bro crinkly smash butt
an ice cream cone that's my man
wait what is he saying about heidi
look it look at heidi she's just like
that's my man crazy smash butt in the
ice cream cone oh that i have a smash
butt that's my man
i hate you're referencing the uh
when i showed my ass then i you know
yeah i crunched it up on purpose bro
you know just to be clear i got a fat
ass though yeah
we don't make fun of you on this on this
show though that's
that's a capital offense that's
straight to the gulag
straight to guantanamo
who are these people
all right well there you have it you
have my offer
everything you want you have no reason
to say no
let's do it right
um
yeah
there you go
and there you [ __ ] go
what else you got yeah so i got um
the ab memes saga on the subreddit it
was pretty epic
this post
so we talked about it last week where
this girl edited his forehead
it was awesome
right
we all loved it
yeah
does any did anybody find out if she
meant it as a troll or
wow
like how intentional was the so my
theory on it is that it's a it is a meme
on tick tock where you
uh but the meme is that you edit a photo
of them and then shu and then you text
it to them and say is it okay to post
this and see if they notice or not got
it
so this one was just a straight troll
a genius troll
it was pretty genius yes
she would i seen her she posted after we
talked about her she was
she's really happy but yeah she's really
nice girl i think it was pretty genius
of her to do it
how do you feel about being the victim
all this trolling
uh
i'm hiding my head from now on i'm gonna
wear this jacket all the time
so there'll be no more edits no it's
funny i thought it was cool i just
didn't know where the hell was coming
from because we talked about this i
think it was over a week ago and like
the the memes were delayed so i'm just
like why the hell are all these edits
when i i get scared when i see myself
all over the sub last time that happened
was with the whole uh
trisha
situation but uh yeah i guess there's
just a delayed reaction but they're
funny i love this top comment that's not
a b that's a d ma'am
yeah so anyway
our subreddit has been completely
dedicated to a b memes
entirely
i think this is the one that set off the
new
chain reaction
they says uh
well a compliment to olivia my by heart
exploding with these two in the same
frame
they don't seem to have edited your face
olivia
they said in the comments that they did
a little bit
i was like why do i look so
really off
yeah they must have done something like
or maybe that's just what i look like
and i don't know but they said that they
did
well
mine's a little bit more noticeable and
so then there it just kept on going the
first couple i didn't even notice you
didn't notice this [ __ ] maybe it looks
like mr bean in that photo i think
that's that i don't spend a lot of time
on stuff so i'm just like scrolling i
was like okay why
the two of them in the same frame is the
thing i don't know
so
i think though the really good ones are
just subtle enough to wear yeah
you're not sure or not yeah but anyone
know where abe got his code from
sorry
sorry if someone already pointed this
out but what's going on with ian's leg
what is it what is going on now this is
a wild one different guy yeah it's a
different person
um
when olivia gives us this look
i started to get a little more out of
control
did anyone else not know that aby can
play guitar i just learned that today
dude they made me look like george lucas
in this one
davey needs to drop his workout routine
[Laughter]
relationship goals yeah
oh anyone know where olivia got this
hair clip it's so cute
[Laughter]
love keeping it 55th street
she
h3 the heart thermo
it's subtle
you know yeah some are super subtle just
like the bridge of my nose
or something
um the curtain partition looked like it
was slightly open in the last episode
please fix this i couldn't focus
this one's hilarious just what the [ __ ]
is this
head
[Laughter]
uh yeah do you guys know what's behind
that door
where is this what door well i'm so
confused oh that's the yeah i know that
it is yeah
um
really enjoying all the behind the
scenes see this one's real good too very
subtle no this one was just my legs i
think no your face no
yeah your face is definitely oh yeah my
face yeah but they made my legs penciled
thin
havey been killing us with the drip
lately
anyone else love content court i hope
they make more in the epi in the future
this one they made you like
i i don't know what happened here but
they like pushed my nose in indented me
a little bit lots of talent oh there's
38 more you guys
this was our whole subreddit and they
all have like a shitload of upvotes too
it's just a lot
does anyone know what mike a b uses okay
yeah i believe which one is that uh dan
that's a sure sm7 oh that's the ss7b
yeah there you go so you know
there's so many of these
[Laughter]
oh they changed
some of the group photos were the ones
that i didn't catch it even because it
was like
love how everyone looks so happy lately
or whatever yeah it looks fine it looks
relatively normal
that previous one that was lena's little
sister okay i was like that would look
like a real person that's kind of weird
why'd you have to do that
yeah
it's just and then they put who is this
guy i recognize him i'm nice shyamalan
oh the shaman on you okay all right why
not
yeah so anyway there's like a gajillion
of these to be honest so it just keeps
going oh abe shouldn't be photoshopped
he's doing impossible things
[Music]
yeah lena and the one above that one
leva lena even jumped in and added me at
thanksgiving dinner
right i saw this under store that was
pretty funny
that's good
so there you have it you know a little
bit of fun on the subreddit
we love that
i want to talk about the uh
the uh mr beast thing next
but first i need to go to the bathroom
oh i do too okay you want to go
um yeah i'll go
because you have to like climb down and
[ __ ] i'll be right back yeah should i
start talking about the
what i wanted to talk about selling
sunset
you want to get that or should i wait
for you
you're passionate about it
okay i gotta open the
document do you wanna read some
donations
sure somebody donated 20 bucks and said
this is for calzone cam's calzone with
peace and love
let's see
oh i saw earlier somebody donated 15 and
said this is for um the fire ass cameo
that ian gave me
just
i was that's what i was gonna say is uh
just so you know you can send a tip on
cameo and it will actually go to ian
that's right
so that might be a better way
to handle that
uh in the future in the future it's fine
thank you though we appreciate the
donation for sure and yes ian's cameo uh
is a fire or so i hear
um
i have not gotten one myself uh ryan
wilson just donated five dollars and
said sean
that video was such a classic isn't that
great we are still offered it so much oh
it's one of my favorites
uh
what else we got
because we were also leaving with sean i
think at the time that we were oh
yeah there you go
here i'm opening up the bigger
list of them right now
let me just uh just one second please uh
one second
here we go super chats
all right what else we got um my teddy
fresh uphill battle jumper gave me
confidence
uh during a truly
rough presentation of awful anxiety and
was so comforting
pardon ela come on man come on man
all right let me it's awesome
i'm glad that i
could help in a situation like that
absolutely
come on man there it is
uh let's see
i do have the document for me not that i
really need needed but i just kind of
wanted to have it in case for reference
yeah
um but if what
i was just last one somebody donated
five dollars said ila you are pardoned
it's all dan's fault so
it's all good
uh that's fine i i'm i'm okay with that
all right so yeah go ahead um okay i can
open up the pictures well so
last night we were just uh randomly
looking for something to watch and then
there was a new season of selling sunset
as like the
what is selling sunset i'm not familiar
with that so it was apparently like
number three or something most watched
right now
which i was thinking to myself like this
is such a
depressing thing
to hear that because
it's like the most awful show but i we
watch it too it's great of course you
know right but it's so bad
um it's about this real realty or real
estate real estate company
they have an office in beverly or
whatever and it's these two guys
who
own the company i think
and they only hire like
super model looking girls to work there
and it's
super
weird
there you go here's the cast
look at the twins so crazy
they have twins the two guys look at
them
oh my god
how is this real
oh this is awesome
yes and
and um they it's supposedly like a
reality about them
working as realtors and
showing houses and yada yada
i can tell you from our experience
buying a house here
this looks nothing like
reality
i feel like the whole thing is made up
but i don't know
um
so we we put it on because there was a
new season and then one of the girls
christine
is supposedly
nine months pregnant
in the first episode i think
and she's like moving around like she's
not pregnant at all it makes no sense
and she looks pretty small pregnant too
like nine months i don't think that's
possible
so
i also have been having like horrible
back pain all week and i'm like watching
this
and it's like
this is a lie like there's no way she's
nine months pregnant
there's no way you're not the only one
and then i was just thinking like i
gotta look up if photo people are
thinking that too
and uh
we watched maybe like four episodes i
think so somewhere in those episodes
she's having the baby and then they meet
her after having the baby
i think like two weeks after
and she looks like
back to normal two weeks after
and she's wearing like a crop top like
you see her belly
super tight clothes she looks
normal like she was never pregnant and
she said that she had an
um emergency c-section and i know that
recovery from that takes even longer
than regular yeah uh vaginal you know
delivery yeah
so
i started to get pissed i was like what
the [ __ ]
this is insane and why like
i don't know they they shouldn't be
putting this on television and and uh
telling people that this is normal
because that's not
so you think they just made it up for
drama on the show
i don't know or is she faking it and she
had like uh
that's what ethan actually said before
we looked online at all ethan was like
what if she has a surrogate and she's
faking it because she doesn't want to
say it yeah that's what i'm linked to
sub reddit in here post and someone
speculated that too yeah
yeah i'm saying it takes around six
weeks to completely heal from a
c-section
though
yes on a paddle board she was like oh
yeah the day before the delivery i was
doing um headstand yoga stuff i was like
no you cannot that's impossible and then
she yes she posted photos of i think
that was supposed to be two months after
yeah or two months ago right and she's
doing like yoga poses handstands in
bikini she has zero is it this game yes
this is supposed to be two months after
hmm
yeah and she had an emergency c-section
supposedly doesn't that have a scar
associated with that so yeah yes
i went through these photos there's only
two photos towards the bottom where
i it just looks like a water line from
her belly button but i don't see any
scar but it's the only thing that even
alludes to a scar
right there that's one of them you mean
the vertical line
yeah that's not what this car would be
like anyway
yeah that would be because that's that's
my from when you're pregnant though yeah
i have it too that's just like in the
skin
it's like a discoloration thing that
goes away
i've heard of vertical c-sections but
they're
rare to my knowledge but yeah
where is this car i feel like you would
see it here you would definitely see it
you definitely should see it i linked
the video of her telling the story of
the birth
in the dog yeah
uh telling the story of how she almost
died while giving birth okay is it that
one emergency c-section right to labor
you know as we went through the season i
had a very traumatic birth i um my water
broke actually when i was filming i was
rushed to the hospital i was already 10
centimeters dilated wow um so we had to
have a crashed emergency c-section and
um you know i was flatlining and my baby
was flat-lying oh my god we both didn't
almost make it
christine and her baby boy christian
george's are healthy now but the
33-year-old says that experience changed
her perspective on life
i just learned that uh you know i to be
so grateful for for life and everything
the reality star says after that
near-death experience she decided to
share a new side of her on the hit
netflix reality show
realized you know time is so precious
and i you know i'm 33 years old
you know i would have a near-death
experience so
i what i mean hate it because
if she's lying about this like what a
cycle and then the show should do
further research and not allow it to
well she said that
it had she started to her water broke
while filming [ __ ]
so we were i guess wow
but we were watching last night yes
we hate watch this show it's so dumb
did you tell about our theory on the
music no no did anyone watch it no i i
didn't even know about the show okay so
every episode
has like a hundred different songs in it
and they're all like super trashy
weird pseudo pop music like
um i'm getting it on tonight just like
and then they play a whole new song it's
just course after course after course
i'm like this is i think this is ai
generated music
oh
i don't think these songs actually exist
interesting
yeah that is becoming a big thing in
production i just watched a video a few
months ago about the technology of it
has
100 songs and then the next episode is
100 songs and they're all like
sexy pop
right i'm doing it on my own
and then that's it you've seen this
olivia
the first season yeah okay you gotta
watch the second season all right
actually they're on like the fourth
season i don't know what happened
they're on the fourth season
i just what i remember i watched up to
when christine got married i don't pay
that close attention i just kind of like
making fun of it in the background she
wore a black dress oh people say that
trisha stole her wedding from her
let's wrap that part of the conversation
yeah it comes back though i say what i
said let's wrap the other part of the
conversation
yeah so she got married she was wearing
black and everyone else wore white and
that's what trish was doing so people
are saying she ripped off her wedding
that's it peace and love next topic what
winter wonderland themed
is there anything black in the winter of
wonderland
i don't know
but like it was like winter themed coal
that santa brings here
the soul the soul
the soul and the coal are all black oh
hey ela
yes so um
she comes out
you were saying she comes out she has an
emergency c-section and then in two
weeks she's wearing a bikini you can't
see the scar lines i told ela i was like
i think she faked being pregnant and had
a surrogate
yeah i genuinely think she was so on the
show so i'm confused on the show does
she not have a belly she does she does
always like outfits that
cover it
but it's like uh
her tummy is like pretty small for nine
months i don't know and and she the way
she's dressing is like she's wearing
high heels like crazy
and super tight-fitting clothes
it i don't know something just doesn't
make sense well their whole shtick is
there i think what she wants to be
perceived as is like the superwoman
who's like uh yeah she's like the day
the hour before she was rushed into
pregnancy she was showing a house in
high heels
and that's why i was getting upset
because it's like [ __ ] this you
shouldn't be yeah she's demeaning
putting out this unrealistic like
it's psychotic idea that you can do all
that at nine months that's did you show
her like in the bikini like two weeks
afterwards doing handstands and [ __ ] yes
and you couldn't see a cesarean mark no
right we showed that yeah and no there's
there's seemingly no scar yeah and she
said she was had an emergency c-section
which is an extremely invasive
uh
surgery it's very difficult to recover
from
so something doesn't make sense and if
you know her you know she would do that
our friends that had like c-section i i
know because i've seen it takes at least
a month to be able to like
well we have some christine stans uh
okay in the chat who are saying that
this is a bad take there's so many
pictures of her talk to one of them
no okay so then okay so then where so
what are they saying where are her
c-section marks do you guys know
instagram has baby bump pics
i saw it bro
link me her instagram bro those those
pictures are
so photoshopped like her face is not
even
her face okay
i mean i show you the baby yeah i don't
know i saw the photos too they look real
but i don't know
i'm sorry but this is not this is this
is hate this is wild misogyny no she's
doing wild misogyny she's giving an
extremely unrealistic
depiction of
pregnancy and also making she's like
making other women look weak and feel
weak like oh you weren't out and about
in two weeks after getting a c-section
you know
so i'll let me show you the
okay so like everybody's saying the
c-section scar is very low i know that
but the the bikini that she was wearing
was first of all very low
right and super tight like you pretty
much can see everything
okay so here can you just send me the
link down i'll navigate because i know
what to look for okay
here i got it
so you go down to when she was pregnant
[Music]
so you guys say there's pictures on
instagram of her yeah i mean she's on
the show with the belly too
so let's go down
here's here is the extent of her of her
pregnant belly
shoots okay
let's go down go down
okay by the way shout outs to
she was on the cover of
glamour bulgaria
okay
so shout outs
okay
so here she is on glamour bulgaria
i mean again
uh here's one she posted herself or was
this also glamour bulgaria
yeah
i mean this is so photoshopped they
could cover anything in it
right
i mean you could make me look pregnant
with that much airbrush
while i already do to be honest well
there's little nice photos
there's one a little
yeah little gnaws look [ __ ] as
pregnant as she does
exactly that's a great point ela
look i don't know i just all i'm saying
is something is weird here yeah i don't
want to be making these accusations but
this yeah but we are i mean this looks
like a real tummy but what can i looks
real say i don't know there's good
photoshop these days too but you know
like little that's a good point little
knows x pregnant
where's his c-section mark he's lying
about it
you think he would just lie about being
pregnant well not here exactly this
[ __ ] pregnant as she is
you know
so don't tell me it's not possible
look at that belly dude
this is not at all interesting okay
she's serving face though
uh paul i don't care you know
you guys want to do a poll i i mean it
doesn't matter this is just
something that we thought about
not everyone lose their mind
okay
also if you're a stan of her i don't
know what to tell you she's [ __ ] not
even a good person
like i don't know what to tell you i
mean find a better role model uh
seriously i mean here's james charles i
just
all i know is that i'm pregnant right
now and i have been once before
and watching that was making no sense
thank you that's it ask questions people
the truth is out there james charles
what uh you know he even got the he even
got the ultrasound okay
is this a bad take
and he's got the baby emoji so come on
also you guys aren't alone there are
other people on reddit that were
speculating the same thing yeah that was
the whole thing you guys asked
them to look into it and they found a
bunch of them and we didn't know that
there was other theories out there we
just saw it and i know enough about it
from watching the show i was like this
is [ __ ] there's something we were
both like this doesn't make any sense
there you have it
govern yourself accordingly
okay let's move on
thank you thank you all right we're
gonna talk about squid game so
first of all mr beast came out
with his much anticipated squid games
video
the views were insane
apparently it got every mr beast video
first three seconds maybe here let's try
that here let's play make the sound
again irony
wait let me go back all the way yeah i
recreate and go ahead
i read it that's pretty good
i recreated
irish
that's pretty good
you know what and just to prove that i
like mr b's i'm going to like this video
i like the video prove it
i like jimmy so please don't get mad at
me i just did a little clicky baby i do
have some questions though it's
interesting to ask right
um first of all i'll say we had a lot of
questions about this one of our
questions
was
oh did i mention it got like 49 million
views in one day that's like you did not
mention that yet but yeah insane views
just about 42 million views in 24 hours
yep
64 million views now yep it's been out
one day i think or
no
yeah two days two days
yeah here he said i mean that that's
insane
and good for him i mean he deserves it
nobody's ever done anything like this
before
he says it costs 3.5 million dollars to
produce
which is ironic
we calculated that the original show
cost 3.4 million per episode so his
budget is actually higher than theirs
and the winner there's 456 contestants
and
the winner gets 456 thousand dollars
so we had we had uh two major questions
going into this
one was
um
wasn't it sponsored by netflix because
they definitely own the ip
you know right and they would they would
need uh
to have some kinds of licensing
agreement to use the name this whole
time i was under the impression that
this was a promotion for the show
i did too i thought well it's genius
it's actually a genius marketing idea
because he can't use the name without a
licensing agreement he can't use the
sets i mean that's all ip he can't use
the characters the outfits the numbers
the plot points it's all part of that i
guess you could do if it were
if it were clear-cut parody it's but
it's
it's not prepared i guess some people
say it's fair use so as someone who
understands this i mean it's not fair
use he's recreating the game right he's
not transforming it's the first thing he
says in the video yeah irie
[Laughter]
hold on let's get the full statement
because we haven't listened to it i
evacuated every single second okay so
there he basically just screwed himself
if he gets sued
he he has not
altered this at all he's his his stated
intention right is to recreate it yeah
that is the one of the
basic tenets of fair use right
that he's admitting he's not doing which
is
transformation
but okay
um
and then what was our other question was
uh
that we were like man with 3.5 million
dollar budget he's gonna have to split
this
into several videos to get his money's
worth he didn't he put it all in one
phone one video yeah which is he put the
whole damn thing in one video
which i think is actually cool i agree
like instead of milking it for weeks
totally agree he just did it you know he
could have done it in three parts
he didn't
he did all one part
and um
i mean it's really impressive squid game
in real life in whichever one of these
456 people survives the longest one he
also used the music so that kind of begs
the question or is it like weird ripoff
music
[Applause]
the first game we're going to play is
just someone going
right
and they have 30 minutes to cross the
red line on the other side of the huge
room it's interesting in america you
can't uh
copyright fonts
really isn't that didn't we learn that
from our lawyers like like you can use
any font
i think that they did say something like
in israel
there was uh the law is different and
you had to be super careful about what
you used but in america apparently you
can't copyright fonts
that's the first i've ever heard of that
yeah i think
i'm saying that you can copyright it
yeah yeah i think you can too because
you have to like buy licenses for them
and stuff that doesn't sound right fonts
are protected well there you go good
thing i'm not a lawyer
there was something they said about it
but i don't remember what yeah
in the united states fonts are
protectable under copyright law
[ __ ] me in the tits
wait
it doesn't practice what's the
difference between a typeface and a font
yeah because it says okay there you go
see
there is a wrinkle there's a nugget of
truth in what you're saying that's
i mean i might see some stuff that
yeah i don't know i i i'm not a graphic
what's that so i don't know what's
between type font typeface typeface and
font
i thought it was the same thing
well we should get to the bottom font is
computer file
oh computer file typeface is a set of
letters numbers and other symbols whose
forms are related by repeating certain
design elements okay so i think i was
right and that like if you download a
type font type font typeface typeface
oh here so
helvetica you know that font sure yeah
so this says
many people would call that a font it's
actually a typeface
variations of it such as helvetica
regular or italic
or font
okay
the [ __ ] i don't know
subtle very subtle but i guess well
anyway
right
may be protected as long as the font
qualifies as computer software or a
program and in fact most fonts are
programs or software so yeah i think i
am mostly right in that well somebody
had it
if you're using it on your computer
as like a download pack you know in like
adobe or whatever right that's protected
but it's unprotected that's a font right
no that's a type face no the other way
around no that's protected the other way
around
[Laughter]
bitmap fonts are considered to be
computerized representations of a
typeface and are not protected by
copyright law
bit mapped fonts
so the font is the one bitmap fonts are
considered to be computerized
representations of a typeface and are
not protected
there you go okay funk crazy guys
let's go [ __ ] crazy
uh maybe ask a lawyer before you uh yeah
that's what my lawyer told me though
we never had like a serious legal
discussion about it though to be uh
totally front
yeah
without further ado green light
yeah i was kind of surprised watching
this by the way because when i was
watching squid games i was like man
would that many people really go out on
[ __ ] green light red light
some argue that you can copy a font by
recreating it yourself as long as you
don't copy the computer program you're
not violating the law i'm sorry i just
that's probably what you were guys were
told that makes sense
so if you recreate it and just say it's
whatever then you then
you're fine
right but if you actually use the file
the font file that somebody else created
without permission then you could get in
trouble
that's very sounds like tricky it sounds
like yeah
anyway
after that fascinating uh
version yeah
yeah apparently a lot of people did go
out on a
red light green light
oh oh
and as you can see every single player
has a device strapped to them that when
they're eliminated it pops uh chris you
want to have a chance at one red light
i know for sure this guy moved green
light
red light
oh yo
yeah so anyway um you know pretty
faithful
the little packs remote packs that
everybody's wearing william cool
right
is that publicly known yeah okay he made
him well yeah shout out to william osman
because uh i thought that was i mean
just in general the production on this
video is absolutely insane like the yeah
the level of craftsmanship of the sets
and costumes and the way they did those
remote packs and everything is crazy
impressive really cool actually and
um
the way that he detonates it there they
show it kind of here in the marble
portion
[Music]
they want to put 465 000
here you see that
it's sick i mean they made like this
whole technology for it
yeah really cool
so um
i gotta say though
honestly the best version of squid games
recreated has got to be uh you know this
definitely highest budget by far
the outfits
you know everything top of the tops
plus we got that [ __ ] out like a week
after the show became a sensation it
turns out no we were way early we were
too early
enough people haven't seen the show yet
yeah so
let's see
i thought it was funny how by the way
you remember in the show how the tug of
war was like super unfair because they
just picked the strongest people yeah he
didn't change it he's like yeah just
[ __ ] all the dudes are gonna crush
and then
at the there was a very climactic end to
the show where you know they fought to
the death and forgive me but if you
haven't seen it and you're worried about
spoilers then i don't know what to
[ __ ] say
but they did musical chairs that was the
finale
i wanted they could have i mean
they could have battled with like the
q-tips the giant q-tips you know like
damn american gladiators yeah american
glass oh hell yeah it's been really good
like some kind of warfare i mean musical
chairs is like the lamest game in the
whole show that they did
maybe they just ran out of money
they're like [ __ ] musical stairs
you're a budget
you know
well in the actual show like the last
game was the most mundane
maybe they drew inspiration from that
music
besides the killing aspect of course but
thank you a.b the music has begun 456
000 on the line
yeah i guess i mean but yeah they did
fight to the death with the knife
that is sick they made him do that
so you know overall good but i'm i'm
worried that
he didn't get the ip license for this
[ __ ]
i mean you have to imagine that he would
but it's just like there's no indication
of that well
any of the marketing that he did or the
description of the video or like if he
did he would have said thank you to
netflix for allowing us to use like they
would have made him say something like
that right but here's what he says at
the very end which is real interesting
um
and and funny in my opinion
i'm gonna say it dan
yeah i had turned it down before i just
turned it back okay thank you
officially won the very first squid game
in real life ever
congratulations on winning if you
haven't already hit the subscribe button
you have seven days to win ten thousand
dollars and obviously massive shout out
to the creator of squid game we took
huge inspiration from the show and i
genuinely appreciate you goodbye
that's all he said it's just
shout out to the creator we took huge
inspiration
i don't think that's enough
took a huge inspiration you know
ripping off shot for shot your entire
creation you know what if it's not and
netflix is not doing anything about it
then that's kind of awesome
yeah no one's going to ask what you
think if they actually no of course yeah
i don't think so either
you know
netflix and chill netflix is chill
dude netflix has nothing to gain by
taking action against him like exactly
he's literally just promoting the show a
huge
promotion with now has 65 mil it's gone
up like a million by the time we've been
watching it 75 million like if there's
still people who haven't watched it now
they're gonna watch it no i think they
should be paying him
to be honest with you i think they
should straight up just be paying for
this
but i figured they were like because he
always does the money giveaways and
obviously in this one he did and i
leading up to it my assumption was like
oh netflix is you know advertising the
show by giving him a you know four
million dollar budget to do this whole
thing but i don't think it's good policy
to just uh
hope that people don't sue you
because again if netflix sued them
that'd be just a dumb [ __ ] mistake
and everyone would hate them for it and
that me too i would i mean it's just
pointless
but he would have been better from a
legal standpoint probably by not even
saying subscribe button you have seven
days to win ten thousand dollars and
obviously massive shout out to the
creator of squid game we took huge
inspiration but here here's something
that could happen
maybe the well so the creator of squid
game is like an
anti-capitalist or at least the story is
anti-capitalist well sure yeah there's a
critique of it yes and like he he got in
a spout with
who he got in a public spat with some
public figure what was that
he [ __ ] someone said something about the
game and he was like well [ __ ] you too
buddy really yeah yeah oh i must have
missed that what are you talking about
the squid game creator got into a spat
with somebody
over something they said about the show
hmm
what'd you say someone say something
that gabey said he's looking it up
that's all
oh sorry i got cut off um he had b for
lebron james lebron james about the
ending and he says better than space jam
or something like that wait what so here
lebron james feud was skate games
creator is officially on so i'm just
saying like this guy's petty enough to
actually beef with he's lebron said
lebron said he didn't like the ending
that's it you know somebody asked him he
said i love the show i didn't like the
ending okay and then this guy actually
got angry
he said that's my ending the south
korean film director declared if he has
his own that would satisfy him maybe he
could make his own sequel i'll check it
out maybe send him a message saying i
liked your whole show except the ending
so he was actually
he was actually you know
uh
butterhurt
sounds like it a little bit but maybe he
was goofing lebron i don't think so this
guy is serious as a heart attack and
then lebron goes
to respond he said this can't be real
right
with a bunch of crying laughing emojis
uh
so there you go wow
here's the clip that pissed off the
creator
[Music]
thank you
yep
[Music]
wait so this was just like a private
conversation that got picked up by mike
listen the biggest athlete in the world
is saying he liked it he just didn't
like the ending
but my point is that he's a little petty
yeah okay and if and then there's a lot
of people criticizing jimmy saying like
he missed the point of squid games by
basically recreating it and making a
bunch of poor people dance around and
compete with for money right
and so
i'm sure that the creator has some kind
of rights over his ip and he could be a
douche and be like yo take that video
down
he didn't ask permission
right i see what you're saying yeah
it depends if netflix owns it i i think
i think usually what happens in the case
like that is that
netflix owns it but he has some kind of
uh ip
he can decide like where they put the ip
like he has some creative control over
who gets to use the ip for licensing and
stuff so he'd be like yo i didn't
approve this take it down
you know what i'm saying like he could
easily do that damn that'd be crazy if
so
yeah i
yeah
i don't see it happening though i think
yeah i'm just saying just saying just
saying just saying i'm just saying it's
a little risky to invest that much in
um
you know
unapprove the licensing and maybe we're
wrong maybe he did and
though i agree like it he didn't it sure
it seems like there's no freaking way if
he did if he did
and again i'm just speculating obviously
but
there would be something in the
description like thank you to netflix
for
right allowing us to use the license
copyright to whatever whatever
all rights reserve [ __ ] like that
there's nothing about it there's i just
i really don't think he got the license
to this
i really don't it's crazy
but like again you know if he's he's in
that's just i'm scared for him that's
all
but you should watch the video it's
great you know it's awesome
it's amazing what he's accomplished
everybody knows that
and i do think he's a good guy so
don't come for me please
yeah no and again i i did
from a production standpoint i find the
video to be insanely impressive like the
the scale of that also hundreds of
people
he built that whole thing in like what
like
i don't know felt like a couple weeks
which yeah how long did it take them to
film one episode of that probably like
several months
more a year one episode no no no
one season do you mean
the season was probably shot in like
yeah probably three months four months
you think so well
maybe even even less
it's not bad just saying
but
yeah and especially shout out to to
william for his
yeah creative packs i mean i thought
that was so rad how they did william was
posting all about it all over social
that he made all four hundred and
fifty six packs crazy
instagram um production for squid games
was two years
oh
i don't know how long it was editing but
oh yeah
[Music]
well he did the whole pre-production
filming editing and everything in like
two weeks
it's super impressive yeah here he says
uh
i built 456 improvised explosive devices
oh it looks like he built the whole
system too right
wow crazy there you go
very cool hope you got some cheddar out
of that that's a lot of work no i'm sure
i'm sure he did
that's a lot of work dude damn yeah
and quick too
so uh
what do you guys think
think about what i don't know just
general
are you okay so you girls been scheming
on this thing
this whole fashion
i don't know i'm scared now
oh why sick looks of the week well it's
all complementary isn't it
um
right
yeah
mostly i think yeah
i'm so hungry is the food here i'm like
dying i'm literally
dying oh on the way
10 minutes
says sam
what am i gonna do
okay so what do you want you eli you're
leading i'm scared because i feel like
um
i'm having bad takes i don't know why
because you called me fat
and
and the pregnancy thing i don't know
that's not a bad clothes are so
different that's a good take that's a
good observation i don't know what
excuse me anyone in the comments
disagreeing with ela are you pregnant
have you had a baby well the only thing
i'm thinking is like if if i'm
completely wrong then
that's pretty shitty to um
call her out like that so now i don't
know
sure what you were saying it was odd
it's just it is odd
i'm sorry but i was watching this like
this
make any [ __ ] sense right yeah and i
know her okay
you do i mean no no
no
i know what she is and i know who she's
married to okay right and i'm just
saying like it's [ __ ] doesn't make
sense okay we don't need to talk about
that who cares
you should do this you though
um well this is just a little
um pilot
segment pilot segment
because a lot of people have been saying
they would want like fashion segments
so
over the week i just
saved like a few of my favorite moments
that i saw
and this is it
we have justin and haley
so this
was my favorite look really
i think they both look awesome yeah
really
yeah it's just like a leather jacket
what's all the fuss i don't know it's a
vibe
the wide leg trouser yeah that's cool
it is
yeah yeah
you like the white trousers i do mm-hmm
and they're kind of like clowning
they're that's what's in now apparently
they keep saying white house
it's back to uh
what is that like late 90s like giant
baggy pants mc hammer it's coming back
around are you trapped in it
well those are like parachute pants i
think it's a little different
okay why aren't we making pants on teddy
fresh where my baggy ass fits oh true
yeah
so this is for her 25th birthday i think
they were celebrating
she's wearing ysl
and he's wearing jack moose
jack moose
jacques
jacques jacques
jack moose it sounds like
no it's french
jacques
[Laughter]
wonder if i have that one in here what's
so nice i mean that's a nice oh
it's super quiet because i have them i'm
just going to play the ignorant uh idiot
to help you guys explain why this is so
cool i'm totally not asking for myself
but
[Laughter]
yeah i understand everything
uh but this is obviously a nice jacket
but like what's the fuss it's just the
leather jacket
um i just like the whole look the look
of the hole is cool survive survive and
harass too it's not just about him you
wish i would walk around like that in a
big ass [ __ ] leather trench coat
well you can
i look she wouldn't let me leave the
house in that thing like
the only difference in the jumpsuit is
my ass is fatter
okay so we love this look everybody and
then there's sam did you love that look
sam we need you
this is the ladies hour yep
ladies take a b spot the ladies take
over
or i don't know if you guys have an
opinion ian you have opinion about
fashion
no i i don't know i think it's cool are
you skipped right over here
dan come on you don't skip right over me
i can still have an opinion on if what
do you think it looks like of course
speak up i'd love to hear that looks
pretty cool like
cam
cam fine it's fine it's fine
i uh
i don't know i think it's
kind of basic
basic yeah he's got like a cool like
silent bob thing going on
i mean it's basic but maybe it's cool
because his pants are hella big
what's wrong with basic
sometimes it's okay to go back to basics
i love do you have an opinion on this
um
no not really i think it's kind of
kind of
simple i guess yeah basically
sam
love haley
closer
love haley um
justin i don't know i don't feel this
the opposite really i like what
i like what haley's wearing but i like
what justin's wearing more
i think as a couple it's a cool
they both look good i can't see i can't
really make out what she's wearing is it
a jumpsuit we have i think there's more
pictures it's a jumpsuit it's a jumpsuit
and they added the sparkly belt
closer look at the jumpsuit
saint laurent
st lauren
[Laughter]
i'm not a fan of the jumpsuit ew they
got it all tied up at the front like
when you pretend like when you're
eight-year-old and you think that's what
it means to be gay it's texture what
you know what i do know exactly what
you're targeting you put just tuck your
shirt over here don't look i'm we would
say
it's the way it is yeah not necessarily
okay that's what she's doing here
and the bodysuit doesn't look that
flattering
i disagree it looks do you know what the
bodysuit looks like it looks like in you
know when people are writing sci-fi
about like how everyone will wear the
same outfit in the future
that's kind of cool i think it's a like
a thx uh 138 situation
um there's another look of justin and
haley if you
it's an open yes ma'am i'm on it it's
not in right order so go down to the
yeah
that one the bottom one
oh what movie is this
thx yeah that's what she's wearing
no
okay then this outfit i have a lot so
okay this [ __ ] this boots
literally just
they look like baby shoes
don't think these are crazy boots
easy doubt did himself this time
i kind of have those not those exact
ones but for this
easy be like just put your
he's like your feet are like a 40. just
put just bag them
just bag them boy
i love the shoes
you do you do [ __ ] you guys
i love how like chunky they are it's way
too chunky
it looks like they look like a baby feet
they look so small
oh my god
yeah he looks like he has a foot
deformity
they look like orthopedics
yeah that's right it looks like
something the doctor prescribed for his
horrible foot condition
they look like
like the
uh shoe coverings you get in a halloween
costume yeah exactly like just like fake
boots it just goes over your tennis
shoes
so what do we like the look though we
like
i just it's all about the boots
pants are so stuffed into the boots
okay he's out there doing something new
right be like that icon oh my god you
guys
what look how he stuffed in
so bad and then
that's a good observation from uh
from cam he's got he's rocking that neil
armstrong neil armstrong once yeah
made by nasa
wait
what do you have ab
what are you trying to show us
i can't hear you oh we can't hear you
for some reason
you got the boots
you're my friend i have the previous oh
no that's nothing like this get out of
here
those are just normal no those are cool
yeah those are normal you get boots
okay cool you can one yeah you're good
with those
all right so all right so alexa favorite
look olivia
olivia rodrigo
who we love
who's a apparently watches this show is
that what she said ela
um
at some point
she's i don't know she's she
was maybe a fan i think maybe
you know she's very famous very famous
and busy now
but yeah when people become famous they
stop listening
it's just embarrassing at a point yeah
all right so what do we love here
love it um well show the full look too
show the full look
um yeah just
awesome look in my opinion
and in general she's such a this is a
separate look she's definitely a style
icon you think she's a fashion icon yeah
what do we love about this look anyone
have an opinion
all of it all of it
she looks so good
i mean it's a new it feels like new to
me she's rocking the spiky eyebrow real
good i know that's the trend laminated
the spikier your eyebrow the more
the more of a batty you are
right
spike those eyebrows girls like the guy
spiked their hair in the 90s i feel like
it's a perfect combo of because she's
really early 2000s inspired
it's it's very it's a modern early 2000s
you know what i'm saying yeah i'm going
to say it kind of looks like denim
well like the the the sequins i know
it's not but it has the same vibe as the
britney denim uh yeah thing
you also have the same vibe as
you ever seen these
an enemy
i see an enemy
right i flip that [ __ ] upside down you
know do you guys oh that's very true or
like a duster so is that that is a dis i
think it's not really enough it looks
good i'm not dissing it necessarily it
just immediately reminded me of these
things
you guys like all the fluff on the
bottom it reminds me of a uh one of
those lampshades
have you ever seen them with the uh
fluff on the bottom what is it so true
but i like it like in the best way i
love this look in the best way possible
she looks like
a feather duster but in the best way
[Laughter]
possible this is grimace from mcdonald's
why are we looking at this any
resemblance
no no
no what are you talking about
monsters inc any resemblance
no thank you
[Laughter]
thank you thank you all right we love it
she looks good we love her
love the music please come on the show
she was styled by chloe and chanel
she's wearing some dude named david
stress
david david what are you peace and love
peace and love some dude named david
made her dress some named dude named
jimmy made her shoes david coma and
another dude named david made her rings
and earrings huh different david jimmy
choo shoes and david yerman ringing
earrings
david your man
i'm your man he sounds like a car
salesman david i'm your man
you know him no david german
no
you do know
there you have it uh here's another one
ela
all right
you're gonna love that one
what the [ __ ] bro i'm trying to clean my
floor
trying to like sweep my floor with your
sweater arms
koos wears a
oversized sweater yeah you think that's
oversized a little bit
yeah it's a little oversized
when your mom buys your clothes and says
you'll grow into it
one of the comments said
is this a piece you like you or no i
find interesting funny i feel like it's
too funny it's like
maybe in a photo shoot this could look
cool or something like as a statement
but just walking like that looks so
silly
yeah the hallway
also like there's a logistic actual
problem with yeah this you have to
be able to use your hands to some
reliable degree if you're going outside
kind of fire though it is kind of fire
it's a makes i have mixed feelings about
it wait is this a real person or what
the [ __ ] bro you know cgi
i thought it was a fashion show but then
oh
this [ __ ] is out here walking
this basketball player yeah and so that
should tell you something this guy's
probably like eight feet tall and his
arms halfway down the sleeves
like
basketball players kind of always do
like a little bit of a fashion runway
yeah i know for the games
yeah that's like a good ass
opportunity you can rock this look for
only sixteen hundred dollars
well it's a lot of material
you're getting sweaters you can make
like ten sweaters out of it
somebody said he needs the arm
lengthening surgery true
he wants he wants to read some comments
my man what the [ __ ] are you doing
oh that was michael rappaport
oh that's funny
um hell nah
he leave that [ __ ] in hollywood okay all
right
man helma
so
my dog but i'm drawing the line here
someone in the chat said when you're
rich and don't need hands
right that's true
that's a status symbol
come on bro [ __ ] getting out of hand now
i guess he does this a lot with the
crazy outfits
out of hand
oh no oh he doesn't have hands he's
getting out of hands literally
pretty funny
good find you that's that's good love
that
uh more okay so this is it for today's
segment i liked it if you guys like it
please leave a comment leave a comment
keep it going
how long we've been going we've been
going for
two hours and 50 minutes okay this is
love pretty much love submission you
want to narrate this love
this is my last second submission here
this is uh
big punisher
r.i.p
yeah
[Music]
bro they're just styling yeah i don't
know even what to say but just look at
them
well fitted looking like
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
well fitted you know
blinged out
it's all happening
these two you know if you look at these
two anywhere they're like always stalin
yeah my man fat joe may have lost a
little poundage since this photo was
taken
there's another classic of them
oh these guys are a fashion duo
oh yeah oh this is kind of sick actually
i'm not even gonna hate on this i love
that
that's so much denim bro that's badass
that's a great photo
[Laughter]
that's a lot of denim though
i love how long his coat is
i wouldn't be mattified to wear that
yeah
i'd feel so cool
man you could like uh
you could like okay i'm not gonna say
anything easy
what the [ __ ] is this ab
so in 2005 the nba made a dress code
because of how some of the players were
addressing right here uh i forget which
player this is but he's accepting an
award in sandals
that's awesome okay
dude this guy does not give a [ __ ] about
his clothing
and now they've created a monster they
made a dress code and now they're gonna
sweater arms dragging on the floor oh my
god men these days
this is awesome this is so awesome
so this photo changed the nba forever
this is just one of many there's
actually a lot
before the dress code change
this is so funny man i love this
it's like bring your kid to work day
vibes
[Laughter]
that outfit's pretty wild like the jords
yeah red shirt no matching
sockless sandal game that's like high
level [ __ ] right there yeah
high level norm core
oh yeah
zach could fit in here true
with the
here's the dynamic duo
khaled's beard game is so wild man
have to respect it i mean we know he
paints it we we've seen it because when
he didn't paint it his [ __ ] was all
[ __ ] up
he did like a covid video without paint
makeup and he looked so haggard and
[ __ ] up
yeah he paints his hairline in beard
line
this and shout out to fat joe for the
wildest
beard line ever man yeah i was going to
comment on that dude in god's name holy
[ __ ] look at this this outfits i do not
like yo
that's a crazy beard line whoa what's
happening
it's that lineup
oh my god
just wondering it looks like an
instagram filter almost like incredible
i just wonder what's the theory there
does he have a patch there or like yeah
he's uh he's trying to cover up
is there
he just likes the cemetery
sometimes you get used to seeing
yourself a certain way
you just can't yeah
otherwise you think you look bad yeah
maybe there's a bit of that
oh man what's going on but he looks like
did i do that he left the soul
maybe i should try that too we should
all come in one day with roblox with a
little door hole
if he was committed he'd get rid of the
soul patch
somebody said he looks like a
ventriloquist dummy
and then of course the ultimate lineup
um this guy
hard rock
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah
it is yeah
he's like an internet man i'm not super
familiar with him
yeah hard rock nick
here's the nba dress code now after uh
oh here's the same guy yo this dude is
the [ __ ] bro
this guy shops exclusively from goodwill
only
love it nothing wrong with that no i'm
just saying
[ __ ] right here he's got he just throw
on some jeans doesn't matter what it is
sure don't matter nba dress code
no chains pendants or medallions worn
over clothing
can you see what's wrong with that
by the way while we're
at it i'll send in what's up but
no sunglasses
no head gear
like hats i'm assuming no jerseys unless
approved no headphones that didn't seem
that bad they didn't say no shorts
like nothing prohibited
nothing they added there a b prohibits
this photo true
this photo can happen still dj khaled i
don't know how he landed this but he had
a collab with dolce gabbana oh yeah
because dolce gabon is super tacky and i
think there's like a good match there
i really think they're one of the worst
uh high-end brands in my opinion
actually no they had some really nice
stuff lately when we went there
i mean it's always like you know
my my least favorite time and brand if i
can say it without uh is uh gotta be
versace and i'm sorry
i told my versace heads but this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] tacky
but this collab
this is hideous yeah
i mean this is just hideous
yeah i mean i thank you this is [ __ ]
a disgrace
you have to be such a sucker weirdo to
wear it by this and how much does shirt
cost i bet you it's like 1200 bucks no
it's not that bad oh for real uh
600.
i mean still way too [ __ ] much let's
be honest i'm surprised that seems a
that's not that bad but
i mean obviously
in fact let me find some
dude i'm telling you versace is
consistently the worst luxury brand
um
i used to not like dolce gabbana but
they they came out with some fire
actually
uh in their recent collection i thought
looks real nice
that shirt is a perfect example of why i
hate them though
yeah
okay whatever we need but you know for
women they have really nice stuff it's
like it's weird they have this kind of
thing that i hate but then they have
other stuff that are good
the [ __ ] oh you made this right cam
cam sent us this
yeah he's he's squared up on top and on
down
creating that thermal look it looks like
a
water thermostat yes
i'm trying to find more oh the medusa
you look at this [ __ ] bro
they do these print all over
that are just
uh versace medusa
[Music]
they're like comically bad
they had some really nice um
dresses lately though so
i think it's uh
it's tough to just say the whole brand
sucks
i mean yeah it's generalization but i
stand by it
let me show like uh look up
this
yeah this [ __ ] is straight up like ed
i mean look at this [ __ ] look at this
shirt
and [ __ ] i can't get into all this
why just open the image damn
open image a new tab
okay here look at this [ __ ]
oh that's nice yeah yeah that's for a
second just don't put your branding or
any of your [ __ ] on it
just don't let anybody know
yeah exactly you made it
i'm telling you make a mental note the
next time you see someone walk around
like versace like this and you'll be
like wow they're the biggest
douche i've ever knew existed
but anyway
and i can't say i'm a fan of even
this kind of [ __ ] here let me show you
this is like their high-end menswear
like what are you a [ __ ] emperor stop
seriously you gotta log in this [ __ ] is
all the worst thing i've ever seen it's
the doge
it's the worst thing
okay
thank you thank you thank you
peace and love
so while we wait for the food we can
talk about will smith cringe
jk rowling getting ghosts
the food is pretty much here okay bye
everyone
um
let's just wrap it up then
well what a joy what what a thrill what
an adventure we've had here today
on this uh black friday day
hope y'all get some great deals better
than black as well there's a new bts
today
oh got to plug that more next week baby
is it is it up already
i know i have it on drive i'm going to
have dan upload it after this episode
throw it up shortly so for our lovely
members there's a new
bts anything featured in it you want to
uh
please
i will yeah there is more ian in this
one which everyone wants exclusive
it's a new explosive
and ian exclusive
so yeah for our beautiful members not
only do you get
episodes a day early but you also get a
bts video every week
shot and edited
right shot and edited by a b
yes beautiful
love that
uh sam where are these pillows from
people are asking in the chat they're
from ikea ikea
to classic
those pillows sam and i actually walked
around ikea searching for the pink cover
for like maybe an hour and we found one
after so
much time searching
yeah
um this shirt that i'm wearing will be
out on thursday
part of our december
election
black friday teddyfresh.com four more
days of that
h3 shop some amazing merch all proceeds
go to the crew let's go
and um thank you all for being here hope
you guys have a fantastic week
will be back next week full week
four episodes
it's all happening
on the history podcast
live
experience oh i forgot to talk about the
new uh
variant hype new variant hype right new
very did you hear about the new variant
apparently it's like mega there was like
the south africa variant yeah shout out
to south africa
we'll talk more about it on on
on monday because i'll have more to say
about it but it just new study came out
and it's like catastrophic
the market had
like crashed real fast you don't believe
me no just why are we ending this is not
the way to start the weekend off
devastating
people should know and be careful
all
right
ding's been going crazy dr ding friends
of the show has been going crazy about
it on twitter yeah
yeah i guess the news broke kind of that
this was happening like two hours before
the market closed and it crashed real
fast it went down
um
it's the weekend obviously but it went
down almost two and a half percent
whatever that means
yeah exactly whatever the [ __ ] that
means
nothing i'm sure we'll be up ten percent
tomorrow on monday
we got our boosters get your booster
hopefully that hopefully it works
i don't know
the mega hype
let's get hyped new variant baby
anyway happy weekend get your booster
and uh keep your eyes out because [ __ ] i
hope it's nothing but
better to be aware right than not
and we love that that's what we're all
about education awareness peace love and
unity krs
knowledge
rain
okay
knowledge reigns supreme
that's what we believe in here
all right that's a mega good point
goodbye
what you gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew goose and gaps
with all the guests you'll see the best
podcasts in the world take it from me jc
over j hp baby we podcast now